have a quorum so um
i call the committee back out of lunch
recess
and ms rounds are you ready to roll
so i think i think matt
is in the audience to cover 37 so if you
want to do that
first and then i can roll with my
footnotes because i'm not sure what his
availability is
hey matt welcome back mr chairman good
uh can we can we get uh section 37
pulled up
how you doing today uh very good how are
you mr chairman
it's a great day when uh ways and means
are you here to give us the oh you can't
you can't give us the ways and means
update
uh i i would defer to them on that that
hopefully you have good news soon
though
you can you can begin if you'd like
thank you mr chairman so section 37
is a fairly straightforward one-time
appropriation of one and a half million
dollars
directed towards combating social
isolation
and making capital improvements in
spaces such as senior centers
part of the inspiration behind this
appropriation in house bill
2 is that we know the pandemic has hit
older granite staters harder than anyone
else and as part of coming out of coven
and encouraging people to get back out
into their routines and socialize
we know that some of these types of
structures across the state
could use money of this nature to make
capital upgrades or just
other things uh whether it be
programming or
to make seniors feel safe returning to
these spaces
and that's the inspiration behind this
and i'm happy to take any questions but
i don't have too much more than that
okay i did have some questions
eligibility is this
only for county nursing homes is it for
all i i understand we have something
like
240 or 260 nursing homes
statewide is everyone eligible
what what's the eligibility around this
so we would support broad eligibility
this would be something that dhhs would
need to determine as the legislation is
silent on it
but essentially this would be an
opportunity to provide grants or
potentially matching grants
to these entities um
and again for the purpose that i've
already gone through whatever they might
need to
encourage people to socialize and try to
mitigate those negative mental health
impacts
uh that we know the pandemic has wrought
representative
thank you and thank you for being here
again um
i was wondering what would be the
process health and human services
would put out some sort of an rfp
or information so that um
senior centers could apply i mean these
aren't just nursing homes right these
these could be
senior centers in local communities
meal sites where seniors gather
absolutely yes anything of that nature i
don't believe nursing homes are
specifically called out i think it is
more of that community aspect
and if the committee feels that we need
to add the word
competitive process or something along
that nature
just to ensure you know there's some
structure to what hhs would ultimately
deploy
uh we don't have any concerns there um
but again i think the the department
would have that broad discretion on how
to
you see this going to many
senior centers across the state not just
to
one or two that have already been chosen
correct this there's no predetermination
on where these funds would go
or even the size of the grants we see
this as a problem statewide and we know
it's a small investment
but we would want to make some type of
an investment through the through the
budget
um again just to come out of this
pandemic and make sure that people
feel comfortable in the spaces that they
regularly enjoyed prior to the pandemic
you still have the floor if you have
other questions well i guess i
one the only other question i really
have is
this is another new um
requirement for health and human
services and i wondered
um where exactly this might
happen in health and human services and
whether or not they've really got the
bandwidth to do this program at this
point
i mean i think you're right it's um
certainly infrastructure is a is a
problem for a lot of these
organizations so i wonder if you've
explored that though whether the whether
health and human services really has the
uh
ability to do this right now i would
defer to karen
as to that um i don't know that we'd be
opposed to the department having some
portion of this for administrative
expenses
if necessary but again it is such a
small pot of money to
start with but again i would defer to
karen on that particular point
so so thank you oh i'm sorry i didn't
mean to cut you off you were done no i
just said i just said thank you
for the information all right if you if
you have more you can continue
i i do you have more
no okay so um
in what is the maximum number that would
qualify under this paragraph as written
are we you know since we're talking
about all of the nursing homes in the
state
plus other things that may qualify as
senior
centers are we talking about 500 to a
thousand
uh potentially i i don't have a firm
number
um but if you assumed that there was one
entity in each town
right probably 250 is a safe assumption
and obviously there's a lot of
fluctuation there but
again the department would have broad
discretion on how to operationalize this
program
if they wanted to do a minimum or a
maximum threshold
and again if the committee feels that
additional details are
necessary to help set that down a
certain track
we don't have any concerns about
anything like that
well i'm just concerned thank you uh
because i'm just
thinking that if this gets to
well one we have to make sure that it's
fair
and with 1.5 million dollars that money
is going to run out pretty quickly if
there are 250 potential bidders
and then we'll be spending money
on screening and qualifying
and approving grants
and it just seems to me that we could
end up
consuming a significant chunk of this
money on administrative costs
and not getting the money out to help
the the centers
wouldn't wouldn't the more efficient
program just be to write a thousand
dollar check to everything that can
qualify as a senior center and be done
with it
if there's an administratively efficient
way to deploy this funding
again i i think that would definitely be
our preference but
the language as written in the bill
doesn't
specify one process or another but we
agree that it should be
fair and open to any entity that
qualifies
and we haven't tried to prescribe those
those smaller details to the legislation
and i think you would agree we want to
minimize administrative costs because
we'd rather money get spent actually
doing things absolutely
representative i just met i just wanted
to know
um i guess i should probably know this
myself but i don't
so this summer this past summer we've
been gopher
um set up a number of different funds
one of them was a non-profit fund
i would assume that most of these senior
centers are non-profits
do we know how if senior centers took
advantage of that fund it sounds like
it sounds like sort of what what's
happening here are
um things that um
might have been eligible under the go
for funding the non-profit gopher
funding
and i just wondered if you had any
statistics about that
nothing offhand what i would say is i
would agree most of these entities are
either non-profits or municipally owned
and these uh uses that we've
delineated here would certainly be
eligible for cares act funding
and potentially subsequent federal
money that's coming to the state so
you are right that there are potentially
other pots of money
that could accomplish the same purpose
but again wanted to do something
just showing the state's commitment to
again helping seniors get back out
so i think it's a great objective i mean
particularly since we're dealing with a
an age that's particularly vulnerable to
the worst aspects of the disease but um
but i again i'm just looking for a way
to make sure that there's fairness and
transparency and that we're not spending
money on overhead
uh to it too large an extent so
and and and you're mentioning that
we've had had federal money and that we
are having new federal money
so could you categorically today
tell us a definition
of senior center and senior citizen
centers that
just would not qualify for any federal
money
those that are kind of targets of only
us
can help them i i don't know that i have
anything
that would fit into that category that
wouldn't be eligible given that these
would be coveted related expenses which
has been
you know one of those key criteria in
deploying federal funds
and again i think that you know federal
funds can go a long way
you know we wanted to to do something
that shows again the state's own
commitment in hb2 which is why we put
this
modest sum of money there um so
if the recommendation of the committee
is that gophers should run a program or
anything like that
um there are potentially other pots of
money but
just the rationale for why we saw this
in hb2
do you see modifying the language in a
way in which
we say that this 1.5 million uh
is is is to be funded by
you could write that in but i don't know
if that's the
best way to because it would be such a
small portion of what the state would be
receiving
it might just be better to allow that to
happen on its own as opposed to trying
to prescribe
such a small portion of that that money
that's coming into the state
uh in such a way representative norgren
you
you have your hand up but uh i'm gonna
go to miss rounds first
just in case she has a clarifying
as far as administrative uh
administratively
there really is no way to avoid it
administrative work
we cannot write a check unless there is
a contract that
and if it's a contract for more or a
grant award
if it's more than ten thousand dollars
it must go through the governor and
council process
so so there is no way for the department
to avoid
administrative costs with administering
this program
thank you for that representative
norgren do you have a question
no i just want to make a comment that
house bill 2
was written months ago before
we obviously probably knew of the extent
of the available availability of the
gopher money
so that might be some part of our
consideration that
things have changed since this bill was
written
so i think we should consider the other
options if we can thank you
so what would another option be just to
to dry out a little bit further
well i think i think we need to see if
this sort of operation that's in um
36 would be covered by cobra before we
based on you said 36 i think you mean
i'm 37 though right
right yes i do i'm reading without my
bifuls i'm sorry
no problem i'm sorry i cut you off man i
just wanted to make sure we were all
talking the same thing
okay no and i appreciate that mr
chairman i would say based on the the
plain language of
uh the american rescue plan that was
recently enacted
anything that we would have envisioned
through this appropriation
would be covered by those dollars again
i can't point to a
unique loophole that we were trying to
solve
other than again just to reiterate the
state's commitment
uh to helping these types of centers
that normally don't always have the
the money readily available to make
okay miss rounds your hand is up and so
is representative nordgren so we'll go
to representative nordgren again
no nevermind sorry all right
uh do are there any other comments from
the committee
i you know the way i'm looking at this
is i think that it's an important thing
but
i'm just concerned that it would be a
little ineffectual
and that we would eat up too many of
these resources
uh not only state resources and hhs
but you know there would have to be
senior centers all over the state that
would have to fill out some kind of form
so so they would be incurring expenses
too i
i guess i just um don't see this i see
the intent and the
in the in the good naturedness and the
importance of it
but i'm just not this doesn't
strike me as as effectual
and so if if just just
spitballing with you and mr malou if we
if uh if our committee were to strike
37 would would you work with the senate
to to kind of tighten up the eligibility
and
tighten up you know what the process
would be to determine who would get it
so that they can consider because we
can't
uh we don't have time it could so that
they could consider
whether or not this was you know a
cost-effective and
program that delivered what we want mr
chairman
we would either do that or work to
develop a similar program
uh either through gopher or with federal
money so i think
one way or another the the spirit and
the intent of this section
um you know we certainly would want to
move forward with but
whether it's working with the senate or
just using federal
uh money to to fund some of these
similar type initiatives i think to
represent a walnut's point
um you know there would be other
pathways
and i certainly don't speak for the
committee i was just trying to
understand
the the governor's office reaction if we
went down that road so so thank you for
that representative norgren i i couldn't
tell if you wanted to speak again or not
you're welcome well
well if there's a time for making the
motion i would
do that um
okay so i'm going to try to act like
i've learned something over the last few
days and if your motion
requires an amendment we're not ready to
take a formal amendment
but but can you can you tell me a little
bit what you think you're going to
motion no i i we're just going to make a
motion to remove this
and i think that the theory that the
senate will have more information about
gopher money
and they could put it back in if
necessary
yes ma'am i would love to entertain that
motion but i don't think we can because
we don't have an amendment that
strikes this language from hb2 i mean
you actually could
sorry sorry to interrupt i went ahead
and had one drafted just in case you
decided to uh go down that road so you
actually do have one to vote on this
time have you ever watched the tv
show mash i'm now going to call you
radar ripple
he's a mind reader i know i i'll send
him
a motion that's amazing
so so uh representative nordgren if
you'd like to make a motion maybe you
could reference the amendment that mr
ripple has prepared for us
here he is oh and it's got my name on it
so do you want me to move it on your
behalf
please okay i would like to make a
motion to accept the amendment
0905 h please
back him for a second yes there's a
second so
um representative bean i assume that
representative weiler's not here yet are
you
you're aware that that says paragraph 19
correct
the paragraph 19 refers to the paragraph
and the analysis
at the beginning of the bill so it would
okay just just a second big catch good
so ms rounds you're you're you're on
deck uh
because we're we're going to come back
to you you know when we're uh
okay you ready yes sir
okay representative walner yes
yes representative representative rogers
yes irv yes
representative edwards yes
i'm representative bean and i'm a yes is
representative
sounds like he's not it's uh 6-0 with
one
absent
thank you representative bean so the
six to nothing the the motion passes and
we will delete section 37.
um so ms rounds and the things that you
still want to talk about do you still
and and matt you're gonna have to like
teach me phonetically
how to say your name i'm so sorry it's
just it's an embarrassment every single
time
so ms rounds are you ready i am
i say i'm ready and then i don't have my
crap together to actually share my
screen okay here we go
so last night
mr chair you sent me an email um
that then was later revised so this is
just the revised list
of footnotes that you had questions
about i assume that's what you wanted to
chat about
yes those six and then uh representative
earth
caused the question is your typo
great um so we will start with the first
one 29.58
so there was not a footnote for 2958 in
1819 however there was one in 2021
to make that non-lapsing within the
biennium
and the reason that we did that was
actually a couple of reasons
one uh almost all of
our or might be
all of our like top five accounting
units as far as cost
are non-lapsing within the biennium
there's medicaid
there's the developmental disabilities
accounts the nursing
facilities accounts those are all
non-lapsing with the within the biennium
this is the other very large service
area within the department
and so i was looking to treat it the
same as we do with the other large
service areas in the department
the secondary reason which is also a
broad reason
as to why we would make it non-lapsing
in the biennium
we often um
see costs increase year over year
uh i don't think that's unusual it you
know happens
everywhere gasoline goes up not the
greatest example that one loves to go up
and down on a regular basis
but you know the cost of a thing of
paper
goes up you know you know over time so
we
um we of course try to budget for that
but sometimes costs might be lower in
the second year
higher lower in the first year higher in
at a rate more than what we anticipated
so it allows us to
carry forward the funds from the first
year into the second year
to continue to pay for those costs from
a lapsing perspective
across the biennium math at the end of
the day
it all comes out because one
either um we would carry those phones
forward and continue to pay for it
and they would not have lapsed um and
then whatever is left at the end of the
second tier
does lapse um in non-revolving accounts
in which this is not a revolving account
or it's lapsing it lapses the first year
the second year there's not enough funds
i have to do a transfer item to transfer
it from somewhere else and we lapse less
than the second year because
that would have otherwise collapsed so
over the biennium the net effect
should be zero it's really a
an ease of accounting if you will to
just keep the funds that have been
appropriated there in the same fund and
are there any questions i i have a
theory for you
and it's and it's it's my own personal
theory from
having seen government budget officers
work
and there's a use it or lose it
mentality uh
towards the end of the fiscal years at
least at the federal government level
yes where there's a
an aggressive push to obligate
you know greater than 99.9 of the money
and in doing so it seems that i've
witnessed a lot of waste in that process
so which method do you think would
result
in the least waste um having
two fiscal year ends that they need to
manage towards
or to have one big one at the end so are
you asking in theory or in what i
practice of what i actually demand of my
staff
your staff and your practices that you
never waste any money i know that i'm
just
i wouldn't say i mean that's an
impossibility right like i'm not going
to claim that i've never spent a dollar
that maybe
wasn't the greatest plan to spend that
dollar that that would be
impossible right i'm not perfect my
staff are not perfect nobody is
um but talk about the theory
yes i can tell you that we do not
endorse
that methodology i have refused
things like mass supply orders on june
15th
because i don't understand why you need
25 boxes of pens for the next three
weeks if you really need them
why don't we wait till next fiscal year
why don't you order just enough to get
you through to june 30th
because i know what that game is and i
don't play that game either
and my staffer are instructed to not
approve those types of things and they
have pushed back
um on that regularly um
in practice i mean in theory i'm sorry
that was in practice
in theory i mean certainly making it
non-lapsing
just doesn't encourage that behavior
in the first year um it it certainly
could still be i guess
in theory encouraged in the second year
when it does get ready to lapse
so i don't i don't think if we're
talking in theory
it just changes the timing of when that
happens not necessarily whether it would
or wouldn't happen
but again i would tell you that i work
very hard to not let that happen
all right are there any questions
so so i think you could talk about the
the next one
sure so uh this accounting unit 7051
is the chip account this accounting unit
was new in 2021 so
their footnote would not have existed in
1819 because the accounting unit did not
exist
the funds in this current accounting
unit now
in 20 and 21 and 20 23
would have come from 7948 which is
standard medicaid
um these are you know all part of the
mco contract so we are just treating
this accounting unit the same as we are
treating 79.48
okay i'm not seeing any questions
you're on a roll okay the next four
um the first two are the path
center and the next two are new
hampshire hospital
so i'm a little confused that these
weren't in 1819 because we thought
that these had been in place for for
quite some time
um so uh maybe it really was just last
biennium but we thought it had been
longer than that
sorry i'm just looking at my notes
so 21 is the
food costs i believe uh yes so
21 is the food cost 23 is
uh utilities if i'm remembering
correctly
so i would say from a a footnote
perspective
uh to go back to the earlier comment
about increasing costs
these footnotes are more important in
the path center
than in new hampshire hospital because
this is will be the first
fiscal year 21 that we're in currently
will be
the first year that we've had occupancy
7 in that building so we've had to sort
of estimate what the
electricity and utility costs might be
where that has been
a building that has been housing um you
know daytime
state employees so even fiscal year 21
won't
be an exact science because it wasn't up
and running 24 7
residence on july 1.
so it's more important to carry those
forward there at the path center
the other thing with the food costs is
and new hampshire hospital does supply
the food
to the past center the food costs i
believe that contract comes up every
three years and i don't remember where
in this biennium
it ends exactly but there's always a
question of what happens with the food
cost when those contracts get renewed
so that's why we tend to bring those
forward in those class times
so representative earth you've done the
most research in the committee that i
know of
about looking into these footnotes do
you have questions sir or
does any committee member have questions
i would say as usual karen knows has
great explanations
i try i keep way too much information in
my head that's all i do now
um okay the last one
um is a little bit confusing and
and kevin uh pointed this out as well
in an email last night and mary um also
this morning when i chatted with her um
this footnote this accounting unit isn't
budgeted in 2223
20 25 59 that's this grant ended so i'm
not sure
why it shows up on the report so it's a
good catch um
kevin noted that it probably should be
going with the following account 33.80
and that it actually shows in the
pdf of the total budget on 33.80 is that
so that should not be there
so my question is what is this is this a
simple administrative fix for you guys
do you need a
vote from the division three or
something else kevin i don't i don't
think we need any kind of vote right
it's on 3380 where it's supposed to be
so it should be fine
yeah the budget is actually fine it's
just the report that we uh
printed out from the budget system
assigned the footnote to the wrong
accounting unit for some reason so you
do we need a vote on the six
footnotes probably not unless
somebody is opposed to them right
otherwise there's not no vote i mean
unless somebody opposes these
if you're going to keep them i don't
think there's any need for a vote
anyone who wants to delete any of those
footnotes
i'm not seeing anyone wanting to delete
them so so let's
let's cross put node acceptance off our
list
did you want to talk about enhanced fmap
that's a nice topic or is that
somebody else uh kevin can lead the
discussion and i'm happy to answer any
questions
well we want to make sure we've heard
everything that you've prepared to tell
us today are there any of these sections
that you brought some notes in you that
we should be talking about the hb2
sections
um i don't think so and i think uh
looking at the agenda the the tanf
amendment if that doesn't come until the
end when mary is here mary
is probably even more um familiar with
tanf than i am so
uh i actually not probably is she
most definitely is so there's no reason
that she can't speak to that one
without me so representative walner if
if you're ready uh why don't we we go to
you
and bring mary in and that way mary and
or i don't want to put you i don't want
to put you on the spot
are you ready no we're we're ready i
think kevin do you want to can you put
up the new
if you have a second would you try to
get a status on uh
representative weiler could can you
turn around i will yes sir
okay um are you ready
yes okay so i think if you look online
you think it was line four i think it
said to
fully fund employment related child care
i think that's correct right and then
um let me see down towards the
bottom uh right here
um the commissioner he or she shall
in to the extent allowed under
federal regulation utilize federal um
available federal tana funds now that la
that wording was added the wording to
the extent
allowable to put um to put some
um you know parameters around
how much could be used
from uh from that fund
so that i think that was the
instructions we got
well i was the only one who was um
commenting on this because i i think
representative weiler
and and maybe representative erf both uh
acknowledged that this is a a good
amendment
and i just was concerned about the
fine-tuning i mean
just in general i i like to leave this
management discretion in the hands of
the leadership of our departments
and and not be too directive with them
just because if we expect them to make
tough decisions we ought to be able to
ask them to make routine decisions you
know but
but i'm i'm i'm i'm thankful to you for
considering different language and i'm
i'm i'm sufficiently satisfied with what
you've done and
very grateful for your work
thank you um
i i would want to entertain emotion
but unlike the previous vote i i think
this might be one that representative
weiler might have
more interested in uh although
and we would love to have his support
okay
um do you have any uh
so miss rounds and and mary they don't
you don't have any questions does anyone
have any questions for
all right um let's let's uh sort of
um informally just table this to see if
we can come back when representative
weiler is ready
and then we'll call a vote on it if if
that's okay we'll ask for a motion
um what did you learn representative
bean
i learned that uh representative weiler
is going to be with uh representative
majors at two o'clock
to get info from ways and means and he's
trying to
he's gonna try to get back with us but
he's not sure
okay so uh because this is the last day
and we have work to do so let's i i'd
entertain a motion
i've made the motion about i assume
amendment zero nine one
one h and i'll second
okay so uh is there any discussion
on the motion
i'm not seeing any uh so uh mr clerk are
you ready to call a role
yes mr chair representative wallner
yes representative rogers yes
representative oreb yes representative
edwards
yes i'm representative dean my
my vote is yes uh representative weiler
is absent
so 6-0 all right so the motion
passes and we've accepted this and i
assume mr ripple that this will find its
way into hp2 with the proper section
number and everything
yes it will great
great okay miss rounds it's
it's still it's still your your uh your
choice
do you have anything on the agenda that
you you think we're going to want to
talk to you about
um we can talk about the enhanced fmap
uh like i said kevin
kevin can lead the discussion and i'll
i should say thank you representative
walner for identifying that and working
through all the details
so as you heard previously an enhanced
federal fmap
was budgeted for certain medicaid
accounting units
mainly the managed care accounting unit
but it was not
included in other accounting units so
for example the developmental
disabilities accounts the children's
health insurance program
did not assume the same enhanced fmap in
the first six months
of fiscal 22 as some of the other
accounts
so the department has submitted and i'll
scroll down here
a list of change sheets
swapping out general funds for federal
funds
in anticipation of continuing to receive
that enhanced fmap
and there are a total of five accounts
here four within developmental services
and one is the children's health
and we can post these all on our website
too
but up at the top here we have a summary
of the changes
and the net result of this change would
be you would pick up 12.1 million in
general funds
in fiscal 22 and federal funds would
increase by approximately the same
amount
which technically speaking would happen
in the real
world anyways this is just getting our
budget more in line with the reality
we're expecting
i think that's correct this is you're
saving general funds for budget
for budget purposes only here they would
so do you have anything to add to that
mr rounds
i do not other than can i pick the
things that keep funded
can i trade off what you what you might
consider be cutting
to uh business so let me make sure i
understand your question
uh because it's i think there's a real
there's obviously a real question there
but um so we're adding to the revenue
we're actually keeping the revenue lines
the same
so that should in theory not impact
any of those expenses associated with
that accounting code right correct it
doesn't change any of the class lines it
just changes the revenue source
so so restate your question so that i
understand what you're
what you're asking or if it's a joke
that i get to joe
it's it's definitely i mean it's a joke
it is a question in a way but how about
i say it as a statement
i i do hope that by um you know
providing the information on this
12 million dollars that it will reduce
it will result in less reductions to the
department's budget
i understand the request and the
rationale for it
um it's from your position it's an
entirely reasonable request um
so so mr ripple what what is the
appropriate
procedural work here for us to
bring these worksheets into into uh our
proposed hb1 amendment
well there's no amendment number here
since it didn't come out of ols it came
from us
but if you were so inclined you could
just vote to accept the changes
the proposed changes on these budget
pages
is that a relevant vote do you need that
i mean i
uh we can do it yes i i i would suggest
making that vote because you are after
all making a change
to house bill one as introduced
were there um any just conversation
about this still
like uh any any of the committee members
want to ask
ms ron some questions mr ripple
uh representative erf yes i always
obviously fully support this i'm just
wondering karen
in our working with this what's the best
way to
work with it in terms of our budget do
we just accept
we just assume the general funds are 12
point whatever lower and that'll just
work out in the wash when it gets to the
senate kind of a thing
yeah kevin will actually make the
changes in the budget
itself and so it'll be represented in
hb1
okay so the way we work like we can just
basically treat it as a
reduction in general funds and kevin
will compensate for all that when he
does the real work
correct thank you and we're actually
going to vote
on what mr ripple puts together based on
some of this input
i understand there's a we're going to
vote on an hb1
amendment and and by if we vote on this
this will be reflected in
in mr ripple's work and we'll be voting
on that
right is that well i think this would be
the final vote that division
three would take on these items uh it'll
so it'll certainly be included in the
packet that's presented to
the full committee when that exact
session is held and the full committee
would vote on these changes
so um i i i think we could entertain a
motion to
uh accept these enhanced fmap budget
changes
i would make that motion to accept the
summary of enhanced fmap budget changes
into our general fund budgeting process
okay so before that gets seconded a
second
oh you just seconded it i saw your hand
go up okay
all right so it's been moved and
seconded is there any discussion on the
motion
not seeing any uh representative bean
would you would you call a rule
yes sir mr chair representative walner
yes representative noah graham
yes representative rogers
yes representative yes
representative edwards yes
i'm representative bean i vote yes
representative weiler is late it's six
okay so um mr ripple
would you would you please um
that document that you prepared for me
over lunch to show
our status on hb2 yeah
did you share that next is there a
okay so let's let's just chunk through
this
um in sequence um i think we've
we've hit around them uh it says here
representative earth
you have a proposal on a recommendation
for section 24.
yeah yes amendment to the county
reimbursement fund is that what you're
referring to
yes if you're ready to speak to that
yeah let me um
okay i was trying to put yeah fine let
me just go bring it up so i can read it
so i know what i'm talking about so so
we'll come back to this document again
mr ripple but we'll take a dive into 24
okay
okay um i wait for mr ripple to bring
the
so i'm not sure how much of the budget
is incorporated in that
mr ripple can i just speak to the budget
the analysis that might be what i'm
doing in the budget and then we can
tie it into this okay sure um yes
okay so if you want i can bring up that
house bill one amendment that's related
i don't i don't put it on okay
okay
okay so i'll speak to this first and
then this will tie back into
the numbers that are in hb2
so this is the county cap
part of the budget and i'll come back to
this but basically we're proposing to
raise
the cap but before i get to that
something else that happens and perhaps
mr rip you could highlight the
under fy um 22 the 211 000 540 well the
10 000. that's fine sure that's a
so yeah so part of the
amended budget includes
reducing the budgeted item for line 504
in each of the two coming years 22 and
based on and i believe all of this has
been in
this count this discussion's been in
conjunction with
the department is the county is talking
to the department
and the notion is that the counties have
estimated that bed
use rate i guess at 3 900 versus i
believe 4 100 or maybe 4 000 was the
number
used in preparing the initial budget
with the 221 million dollar
number in there so this reduces that
line by 10 million dollars in
22 to roughly 211 million dollars
and then essentially increases it from
there but decreases it from the
originally budgeted amount by five
million dollars to 216 million dollars
so making that change has an impact
on the county cap as well because it's a
lower total expense if you drop down to
um
i guess it doesn't get there you go
thank you um
so so that has gone that has dropped
down
okay so now down to what the in addition
to that change
the underlying change is as follows so
the state
is obliged to maybe it's the wrong word
but in any case
my word is bad just correct me to
allocate from the general fund five
million dollars
against the costs
above which include the nursing home
payments that's obviously the primary
one
but it also includes the other three
lines 505 506
529 which are related but
less less costly um and what the
proposal is
is to well let me go back traditionally
the county cap
has gone up roughly from i understand
historically two to three percent
per year naturally last biennium and
maybe even the one before that it
started to change dramatically
and i recall that we on division three
last biennium
put in uh budgeted basically an
increase to the county cap i don't have
that number right in front of me but
um we did and the idea
this by aim is to do something similar
and to build in
a two percent cap per year
increase and the the net effect of that
is what are the numbers um
is that the 14 million 550 it's just i'm
sorry kevin it's a different way that
i'm looking at it is it the 14 million
550 is that the
general fund increase and effort there
we go that's correct yes
so that increases the general fund in fy
by the 14 and a half million and in 23
so that is the budget
so let's go back to the hb2
should we take questions on this
absolutely of course
i just want to make sure that everyone's
had an opportunity to
absorb what you just said and make sure
they understand it
so i i just want to throw some numbers
at you that i remember
from uh one of the briefings and that
was
that the county said that they had been
asked
to budget at 4 100 nursing home beds
and they thought that was too high and
therefore
their expense line was higher than it
should be because of that
that estimation of nursing home beds
and that they advocated that that number
instead be
3 700. and i'm seeing 3 900 there and so
i just am testing my memory
did that want to be 3 900 or was that
supposed to be 3 700 in the footnote
well when i looked it up in my uh email
this morning from our
county nursing home administrator who's
been pretty involved with this
he gave me the 3 900 number and he gave
him the other number as well but i don't
have fun of me but i did send it to
kevin did i say 4 000 cabinet or 4 100.
4 100 originally down to 3 900. okay so
those are the numbers that came from my
county administrator that's all i can
speak to mr trump no no that's great i
just am just double checking my memory
on the 3700
estimate so so the 504
decrease of 10 million dollars is the
result
of reducing the estimated nursing home
beds by 200.
correct for next year for 22.
and since it looks like we're carrying
that into the second year of the budget
we're expecting that 3 900 nursing home
beds
to still be a good estimate well we're
expecting it to
we're expecting the bed counts to go up
because we're only reducing by five
million in the second
does the footnote need to to say that
we're using a different
um well you you don't really need a
footnote at all
uh but similar footnotes have been in
previous budgets if you wanted to
include this you could say the
appropriation in class 504 reflects
an initial okay an initial caseload
assumption of 3 900 beds or you could
simply say
an assumption of 3 900 beds in fiscal
year 22
and be silent on 23.
okay so to me a footnote helps the
reader of the spreadsheet understands
under to understand key assumptions and
this feels like a key assumption to me
so i i'd be tempted to include that in a
footnote but
um but i've never been an accountant so
um i is there a reason if there's no
reason to not
include the extra detail for the second
year
i i i think i'd like to see it done just
so that
the senate knows what they're looking at
i don't actually have detail of the
number of beds i think it's built on the
fact that they're expecting the bed con
to start to go up again
as the covid uh pandemic
wanes yes sir that's why i was thinking
that we were using a different bed count
and i'm just trying to see if others
think that we ought to be explicit about
what
estimate we're using in the second year
and i'm not hearing
a lot of yes that we should be explicit
from a department accounting perspective
it doesn't change anything for us if
if there's not enough funds in there or
the bed count ends up higher and so the
costs are higher and there's not enough
funds we have to transfer funds from
elsewhere in the department so
it doesn't really change anything from
our perspective
okay representative walner your hand is
up
well just i mean i'm reading the
footnote and i
i guess if i were just reading it i
would assume we were using 3 900
so if nothing else we should stipulate
that that estimate's
is that your point representative no i
just i'm just saying that when i read it
i
i just assumed when i read it initially
i just assumed it was for both years
i didn't you know so i guess you could
make you could make it more you can
make it more detailed and just say for
22.
so i think i'd rather delete it or make
it more precise
you know right now it's ambiguous and
do you have a recommendation for for
that mr ripple
i think you could vote on this uh if you
were inclined to vote on it today
with that change um and that's the
version that we would
put into the budget and i'm actually
trying to find this in excel right now
so i can just change it right now and
you can vote on that
actual language okay
perhaps you're gonna say full case load
or fy22 either initial caseload
assumption
or in fy22 let me just try to find this
in excel while you're doing that
i i want to tee up the other part of
this spreadsheet conversation which is
um we we would be making a decision here
to to change fy 22
to add 14.5 million of general funds
to the this this line to this account
and that's that's a that's a big
decision and
it would be good to get uh feedback on
that
from the committee can i make a comment
would that be okay yes just so the
committee understands regarding the way
since i was starting with the fy21
adjusted base that has built into it
the county cap figures from the current
biennium
so in fact in terms of our thinking
about what we're adding in in general
in terms of what i shouldn't say we what
i'm thinking of what we're adding into
what i viewed as the general fund base
that was in those documents that you all
that one page document i
we went through a while back that the
net
impact is about two million dollars
slightly over two million dollars per
year so all total it's about a four and
a half million dollar general fund
increase over those numbers that i
provided to you
any questions about the general funds
line
no i'm not seeing any is is the third
thing
on this representative earth
something about the sequence of
allocating
funds that's all in the
hb2 amendment that i was we can go back
to if you want to i can go through that
this is just the numbers for 22 and 23.
so so mr ripple i see that you've
changed line 30 or whatever that is to
include
more precision on the note thank
thank you for that
is can we see the whole section 24 in
this view
or or do you need to go one smaller oh
this is really long ages that's all
right
then it's too long to try to get into
one view sorry
well there are there has to be parts and
we can talk about that and he can move
as we go
and i'll start with i think i think i'll
be speaking about the top part for us a
second
and correct me if i speak about them the
wrong order kevin
but there are basically three parts to
this one of which
is a replacement for the current hb2
part we'll come to that that's the
numbers
the other two are as follows and if i
left one if i if i'm
not including something i'm sure karen
will remind me so right now
the funds as budgeted there are three
uh streams so to speak there's the
initial five
million dollars from i shouldn't say the
this is the ordering but these are the
the the streams the five million dollars
that the state is obliged
there's the county cap and there's the
additional general funds that we're
asking the county to
include i mean the state excuse me to
include
and my understanding is it has currently
implemented
the funds the the
uh i believe the five million i'm sorry
yeah the five million dollars
is the first money spent toward the
total
the general fund increases the second
stream applied spent toward that total
the budget total and the county cap
is the last stream applied
now the effect of that can be if they're
if it goes over then essentially
the counties
oh how did i say that i think i said
that backwards
i believe the other way around the
counties go first
then the general fund excess then the
five million dollars
so the counties basically get drained
and then you hit the general
and then you hit the five the general
increasing into five million dollars
which means that if you go over the
budget essentially the counties have
already paid everything in
and the state essentially didn't pay in
the last bit and my understanding and
again
me if i'm wrong but in some sense this
is related to
discussions about enhanced fmap which
are to be honest a little bit
in terms of actual numbers beyond what i
could fully grok
um but but instead of trying to as as i
understand it
instead of trying to account for the
enhanced fmap
in these lines and how they relate to
whether the county should be in
part of that or not the agreement was
just to switch it around so that the all
the general funds are applied first
expended first and then the county funds
so they so
to the extent that they go over the
budgeted
amount the counties are not spending
that last those last dollars
and that in some sense that balances
things out and karen i just
if if if i'm totally wet there please um
correct me
so yes this section does
if there is an enhanced fmap which right
now there is
we're anticipating that there will be
for the first two quarters of fiscal
year 22
so this statute change presumably would
affect those two quarters
the enhanced fmap would get paid out
or or would i shouldn't say that the
enhanced fmap would still get paid out
to the providers
however the amount that the providers
receive
would not change because of the enhanced
fmap
the offset to county funds would then
result in county funds going back to the
county
um kevin
can you also bring over henry lipman he
just sent me a message he's been
listening and
um has some additional input that i
don't want to miss
um so
what i would say is just from a policy
perspective do you understand that
currently
the additional funds that result from
the enhanced fmap get paid out to
every nursing facility in the state um
and this would change that that
that the additional funds as the result
of the enhanced fmap would go back to
the 10 counties
and henry you said you had an additional
comment there
yeah i just want to make sure i heard
representative erf correctly again for
the record this is henry lipman the
medicaid director
in terms of how the county
cap funds flow to pay the expenses
the the five million credit is taken up
front
then typically because the cash flow
is 40 uh counties pay their county cap
amount 45 days
in arrears there's general funds use so
typically what's ending up happening is
the the five million dollar credit
and the last session was a little over
nine million dollars
those funds are moving first um
i think the issue that that karen just
highlighted
is that under current statute the
the enhanced fmap that ends up in the
nursing facility line 504
by statute ends up being distributed to
all providers as opposed to being a
credit to the
the cap and i think that's what this
language is attempting to
address when there's an enhanced fmap
situation
and i think similar to your earlier
discussions
this afternoon on something i think you
deferred
vote later there there are times and for
example in the american
rescue act plan that was just approved
by the president there are conditions on
the home and community based service
enhanced fmap that just got passed that
says it has to be spent on
should i continue i'm sorry go ahead no
i i
didn't mean to interrupt you keep going
it's the floor is yours
yes sir so you want to scroll up
so this next piece with the numbers in
it
is basically what's in the current
budget except with the numbers i mean
i'm sorry
in the current hb2 number
24 except the numbers have been modified
to correspond to the increase
that i described you when we're looking
at the budget with the two percent
increase in the cap in 22 and another
two percent increase
in 23 and then if you continue scrolling
up well actually i don't have to it's
right there
so the third part of this sets
that two percent increase going forward
um so that in the next biennium the and
of course
these can all be changed by the
legislature but this would set it such
that
when the state when the department
um does in their initial budgeting they
would essentially be including
the county these adjustments to the
county cap that have been going on over
the years
in their initial budgeting as as opposed
to simply having in the
5 million dollars so i think that covers
all three of the
could i just mention something on that
of course um
i just want to make sure that it's
understood that the consequence of that
is that there's commitment of additional
general funds so if there's a
increase in the number of beds or an
increase in the cost of nursing
facilities or cfi
um at a rate greater than two percent it
means that
there will be potentially significant
additional general funds appropriated
mass can i ask you a question yes
i'm assuming in that case that the top
line would be going up the the
the budget line the correct 504 line
correct but if we can only increase the
county contribution by two percent
the rest would have to be made up with
general funds
yeah that's the way that's what it is
now correct and that's what we're
talking about
okay yeah i mean the expectation is
that i'm sorry but go ahead pretend no i
just was gonna
address what i think ms round's point is
is that
um the the lower we fixed
that percentage like it's been three
percent
you know the last few years if we made
it two percent it essentially
exposes the state to more inflation
risk than they have now and
and and and so if there's a reason why
that makes sense
i would say it it may be because
um the county when they go to get money
they're going
to one source and that's property taxes
and we have an enormous issue with
property tax
being escalated uh
and we don't want it to get escalated to
the point of exceeding
fixed income earners cost of living
adjustments and the like and so
so i think i think trying to
set a course at a two percent level
instead of a three percent level
is is is just meant to reflect
that if the state needs to find more
money it needs to find it somewhere
other than property taxes i think that's
what that's saying
and and and i know you don't necessarily
agree because you're just making a point
so i just wanted to give you what i
think
the full side of that of your point is
yes and i don't have an opinion
either way it's a policy decision to be
made by the legislature i just wanted to
make sure
that was understood yes so
are there any questions from the
committee there's a lot of information
here
representative wallner do you have a
question
no no thank you
so when we looked at the spreadsheet can
we go back to oh there's more
uh words here is there more stuff on
hb2 we should be talking about because
there's more bold letters
like why line 20 did we talk about line
do we need to talk about line 20 it is
bold it's
it's a change
i believe that's that i didn't happen it
was the wrong place in the
amendment representative talked about
this earlier
that's the allocation order that's part
of that yes
sorry no that's all right uh
can if are we at the bottom of this
amendment
okay i have absolutely no sense what the
committee is thinking about
this does anyone want to volunteer
thoughts
nobody wants to volunteer thoughts so
i think we have to wait for
representative weiler to come back on
this one
before we um have any motions
um all right could we go back to your
sheet uh that you were showing us we we
just
saw section 24 and we took a diversion
and you're getting close to having to
leave uh ms rounds
what do you i just want to ask you again
because we value your input that if
there's something that you think you're
prepared to speak to or may need to
relative to any of these sections that
we haven't closed out
gray represents closed out um so i would
say
26 and 33 are
probably
two that i would like to participate in
if you plan to talk about them today
yeah
i think i actually would like to vote on
26.
so so let's um i'm going to make a note
that we're skipping 24
and too so we can get to 26.
26 there
there was some discussion on it the
other day
um and as i recall the governor
had uh or the off the governor's office
the people
terminate the flexibility january 1
of 2023 which is just
was interesting because it wasn't the
end of the biennium
and so um if we agreed with the governor
we wouldn't do anything
we would just leave that and i don't
think we have an amendment prepared to
do anything to section 26
anyways are mr ripple are you aware of
an amendment
for section 26 i am not
so i i guess that means if nobody's
trying to change it then we don't have
to even vote as a committee because
we're just rolling with what's in hp2 is
that a proper
you you have been taking votes to keep
sections in
uh so in order to be consistent i think
he would vote on this one too
okay representative i'm i'm just going
to say that i
i would vote no
on this on this section i feel it's much
more
appropriate to go to the end of the
biennium um it's just
a small thing it's just a little
different of opinion but
um i didn't prepare an amendment
okay so um i i genuinely appreciate that
feedback because i'll i'll defer a vote
on that
um did did you have a comment ms rounds
i mean you you decided this may be one
where you had something for us
no i i just want to make sure to be
available for questions i i think i
testified to how important i think this
is to
to keep for the biennium and um
i know the the governor's office has you
know
a different belief and that's
understandable but i
i feel really strongly about it being
all right you've raised your hand
yes i've been comfortable with changing
it as well i mean putting it back the
way it was
changing it from what it is now i guess
um
it helped make sure i'm sorry what it is
now
is it needs to be amended because right
if we
left it alone it would have expired in
the current
fiscal year so that we basically have
two decisions one do nothing and it
becomes january 1 2023
where we ask for an amendment to change
it to june 30 2023
do you have a preference on which of
those two things we do
i guess i'd be inclined to ask kevin to
make such an amendment
to change into january i'm sorry
10 30 at the end so change it back to
june right okay change it back to what's
in the brackets june 30 20 21 thank you
june june 30 2023 okay
sorry yes correct i'm sorry
i'm a little tired we have a machine we
got to go we got to keep going forward
no i apologize all right if we have a
time machine i'm going pre-covered
just for the record i think when i'm
going back i'm going post code
yeah post comment that's better i'm
going to age
23 myself i don't know where you guys
are
okay so um so you've got that you're
going to
all drafted so we'll skip further
discussion on that can you go
and this was the one you voted on some
tentative language the other day and i
said i needed to put that into a
formal amendment from ols and i have
that so i can just pull that up
momentarily
um
okay ms rounds would you just remind me
what we were thinking when we
asked you to come up with different
language and i know mr ripple
got this done for us but i think you you
you crafted the language initially i did
and um what we were thinking is that
the original language was added by the
governor's office i did not have
an opportunity to discuss it with them
before they put it in hv2
and so when the document became public i
shared my concerns with the governor's
office which
they um immediately understood and
realized that there were some unintended
consequences
and as such um were comfortable with me
drafting
language uh to meet
the same goal which is some transparency
around when
we accept federal dollars that may
supplant a general fund dollar
um but not to put a restriction that may
i'm not seeing any questions i i think i
think we could take um
a motion on this should i make a motion
the amendment number zero nine zero
your hp two
is there a second i i can't tell
representative if you want to make a
ma'am
can you unmute her rook mr ross i'm just
i was trying to enlarge it so i could
read it i said uh
if if if you're not ready for us to vote
on it it hasn't been seconded yet we can
could could karen speak to it again i'm
sorry i was a little distracted and then
i couldn't read it so
of course so the original language the
governor's office
had put in hb2 uh said that and
let's go back to the original language i
have the original language
in front of me okay
so the that language said any time that
the department
uh accepted a federal fund either
because of a change in allocation or
what they call the miscalculation
or due to a new uh program that any
general fund it supplanted
would be lapsed um which the
the most um sort of forefront example i
can give you is the enhanced fmap with
standard medicaid
we wouldn't have had enough money in the
medicaid account uh to pay for current
caseloads if that had happened
so we would have been forced to lapse
money in the out of that account
and then had to either fund find funds
elsewhere in the department
or come back to the legislature and say
we need money even though we're lapsing
these
this other money so um and then when it
comes to cost allocation sort of a
secondary example
you know they're are times when a salary
like mine might include one fund source
that's a hundred dollars of general
funds
and the allocation might change that
might offset that general fund and then
but i might need that general fund in
someone else's salary because their
allocation changed in the opposite
direction
and we wouldn't be able to transfer that
we'd have to lapse the dollar and then
find another one
um so the governor's office realized
that they were
uh that that was going to put some undue
burden on the department and so
they wanted still some transparency
around when that does happen
so the intent of this language is that
when we go to fiscal committee with a
transfer item with an accept and expend
that we will report on when that might
be happening
and then what the plan is for that
general fund dollar have i transferred
it for another purpose
am i using it for another purpose or
will it actually lapse which in
many cases that does happen for example
when we were talking about
additional 4e earn earlier today when we
earn those extra federal dollars
in all likelihood we're going to lapse
that so so there are times that that
does happen
but the language was was written in such
a way that it was not going to work
so we thought here was reasonable the
governor's office agreed
um is that helpful
okay we have a a motion and a second
to adopt amendment 2021-0908
there being no discussion uh
representative bean can you take a role
yes mr chair representative walner
yes representative noah edwin
yes
yes representative earth yes
representative edwards yes
i'm representative bean i'm a yes
representative weiler
is still absent so it's 6-0
so uh so i guess i guess we just about
hit your
your end time 226 um
do you uh miss rounds uh so thank you
for coming in today if you want to go
away now
um thank you so much for your help
and is mary on the panel so that we can
continue
random conversations yes chairman i'm
here
all right all right um let's go back
to the sheet on hb2s
this is the language regarding
prospective repeal of eligibility for
access to the state's mental health
system
so i think there was i can pull up that
section
although the section itself
isn't very instructive um
yes we had we had some dialogue with
the public on this mr skibby had some
suggestions
um i balanced them off of the policy
committee
the policy committee initially said that
that everything was okay because this
was going to be a moot point
any moment because there's already been
language
adopted that is to go into effect
uh and so this was going to be a moot
issue and i was expecting to be able to
come in here
and say we can either leave it or or
delete it because it's going to be
irrelevant here
pretty soon but then there was some
follow-up
emails on it and and the policy
committee came and said ah
maybe there is a reason to amend this
so um i did not ask for an amendment to
be crafted
and i don't think uh mr ripple that that
based on that email exchange you
probably uh didn't
have uh any cause to do
an amendment i didn't draft an amendment
based on that email exchange
um i did draft two standby amendments
just in case
in case you decided to either take it
out or in case you decided to accept the
language provided by hhs and discussed
last week
but i don't have anything based on the
okay so what i'm thinking maybe we need
to do because
uh i i do want to move past this issue
uh today to put as much stuff to bed as
we can
i i i think i would kick the can on this
over to the senate um
because there's a couple different views
on what we should
what this language should really be um
so i think we can accept the governor's
language
and then i can take a homework
assignment to try to
figure out between mr skibby and
representative marsh and
in the governor's office what this what
this language probably really wants to
be
so that that's that's my thinking
well i mean i was i was thinking
i guess i was thinking that um
[Music]
we could just take it out i was actually
on the i was actually on the opposite
thinking here that we should just take
it out
and um if there's a need for it i guess
it could come we'd come in in the senate
um if there's no need for it then it'll
just stay out
okay i could go with that approach as
well
so um are there are there
is there more conversation about this
anyone
i don't know what happened to my screen
where i see everyone
let me see oh there it is uh
okay do you have further comment your
hands still up representative
oh sorry sorry about that
i'm blowering it there any comment is
anyone predisposed
to go to do anything with this 25 other
than
either keep it or or delete it
and we don't have an amendment to delete
it so i think what
if we did vote we'd be asking missed
ripple unless you created an amendment
to delete it did you
radar ripple okay that's twice
that's great all right so i can bring
i think you've done this before
he's a mind reader yeah
okay so we have an amendment um
it's a pretty simple one does anyone
to accept uh 20 21 0
9 0 4 hotel yes that's it
okay so um representative bean would you
would you call a vote yes sir
representative wallner
yes representative yes
yes thank you representative erif
yes representative edwards yes
i'm representative bean i'm a yes
representative wyler
is still absent that's six zero
motion being past six to the zero uh
this is adopted we'll delete section 25.
all right uh very good uh so
we've done 24 25 26 i think we've moved
past 33 34
is not ready for a vote we will not vote
vote on that today
take a vote on monday and i know that's
pushing it
mr ripple but i don't i don't think um
this is this is right for a vote okay
okay so uh we just talked about
section 35 before lunch
so let's let's get a sense of where the
committee's at on that one
uh do you have a document that you could
show us to just show their
you know the page they used the five uh
the matrix with the five items i think
this is today's agenda
um i can't find it i don't have it up
so just to kick off a conversation
i've not read the report um
it's it it it seems to me like a
m is probably a pretty credible
organization and it seems to me
like they grounded their findings in
hard academic data um
i haven't seen the way they did their
cost analysis or benefit analysis
but you know i i i would be more
comfortable if i did
just look at it to double check it
but um but we're getting this a little
late
in the process so that that's
it um and i i have not
for whatever reason taken the time to to
do a deep dive into this a
m study or these recommendations
uh i i think i could get pretty
comfortable
with the top four um
the the bottom one the dd redesign may
have the biggest
actual impact but uh
i i personally am in uh
a little uncomfortable with the notion
that the state is
picking where group homes are going to
go and and
and those aren't developing organically
to the community and i think i mentioned
why because is the state the state
funding as i remember on group homes
is is actually to keep them sustained is
actually pretty small it's remarkably
small it could be like
50 or something i wish i recalled the
numbers but
the charitable donations for ongoing
maintenance of these things
is really critical so
so i i could see being an advocate of
the top four
and i would just really need to be
convinced
to go with the fifth one the dd redesign
that
that's my conversation does anyone want
to
i guess i'm not inclined to go over 10
million dollars
at this point in the process um
from sort of macro point of view the
first four also look
relatively reasonable to me in terms of
something
or we could pass on to the senate
presumably they will have
had more time to get in and actually
analyze this but if the choices are
between the 10 million or nothing i
would go with nothing
if the choice was something in between i
would as you indicated that the first
four
seemed like a reasonable thing to budget
at a late date since the total i think
is around 100 600 000
yeah it is about six hundred thousand
good good eye uh
representative rogers
yeah um i'm just wondering about
what if we started this in the second
year instead of starting it
um in the first year of the biennium
it's a four-year project and i know
everybody would like to start it in the
first year but
it's something we've done quite often
with projects like this is
is in order to save some money in this
year's
in this budget started in the second
year
um and cut the cut the expenditure in
half
maybe um so that we spread it out
instead of
um in the first four years that we're
doing it um
it becomes a five-year project from now
to uh get ready for it so to speak and
um start it
in january of next year instead of this
year
and i mean it's not the appropriation
doesn't lapse
anyway until june we can extend the
elapsed date out to um
june 30th 2024 maybe
um and look about saving some money that
way
just a thought thank you for that uh
i i mean i think that's a really i think
it's a really good
idea i think it's a great idea because
it would also give the department
some time to um have more conversation
with
providers at this point i'm i'm a little
worried about
i want to be sure that providers um
have have the time to for the input that
um
is really important for the planning of
this
and as far i know that the first four
are very important and i agree they
sound very good i really
the dd one i'm very concerned about us
having
that that just seems like
incredible that we are um
sending new hampshire residents to
florida
to be cared for they're away from their
families
they're some of the most people with
some of the most
um intense problems and issues
of any clients that we have in in our
systems
and we send them to florida and i i
think we i think we need to find a way
to
i'm glad that they've identified this i
had never
really been aware that there were that
many um
that many of these clients out of state
so
and especially that far out of state um
so i i would like to see it i think the
idea of pushing it out a year is a
is a good idea and it also gives us time
to talk with providers
your hand is up and you're free to speak
representative norgren
okay i didn't hear you sorry um yes i
would echo what
mary jane said i think there are all
kinds of concerns
to us that never even knew about the
people being sent to florida we knew
about the people
the children who were going out of state
who weren't in sununu
um so there are all kinds of questions
about the cost
of that and where that even appears in
the budget
all those people have gone to florida
and other places
um and i and then i would also have a
question of whether or not
we can extend it i agree with not
starting
till the 2023 but i'm not sure we can
extend it to 2024 there would be an
representative well do you want to you
know let's
mr ripple do do you understand the
question there and representative
i think it could be extended
yeah i just think we need a lot more
information
about the current situation before we
can really launch into
a whole new plan thank you
um i tend to agree with that concept i'm
wondering
if we're going down that road would it
just make sense to put in a bill
next year to that we'll go through the
process
and we'd also have more importantly i
guess a better idea of
finances the state's finances by that
time
will make it easier to uh perhaps
go for the whole failure at that point
and be able to deal with all the people
in florida as well as all the other
parts
so are you suggesting that another
alternative would just be to
uh try to have this become a house bill
with a fiscal note sent to a policy
committee and we would
correct what do people think about that
as an alternative
um i guess i would think if we wanted to
go that route
i would rather that we um pull it out
similar to what we've done with the um
forensic unit and a couple of other
things i think and keeping ourselves
because it's kind of
our you know we heard the first thing
but keep it ourselves
and we work on it so that it be um
possibly we could
put could finish it this session um or
this year
have it ready to go so that they could
actually start on into january
of this year of next year rather the
second year of the biennium
but i think that we've started to hear
everything and
maybe we should continue it um and maybe
we could ask
um whatever policy committee be it um
health and human services or whether to
sit in with us
i know that's something we've done in
the past in this committee
it's had um one or other policy
committee sit in with us
and work with us on it um but i think it
would be
i'd like to see us do similar to what
we're doing on the forensic unit um and
keep it here and work on it
after i know that that um you've done
that with the other one
mr chairman i think that that might be a
route to go where we started
and it's something that that we know
what we're looking at and how we're
we want to deal with it um maybe combine
the ideas
the two ideas of um pulling it out and
working on it but keeping it here and
and having us where we know the money
part of it at least
and how to spend it and how to go
forward with it do it that way
all right um representative aldrin
walner and nordgren sorry you just
became one person there
uh do you if uh you all had
previous comments you know do you want
to take another
iteration here go ahead
represent norton yeah no i think we're
all sort of going the same direction
that we don't
want to start it now i i and i would
maybe agree with kathy that we could
include hhs committee in our discussions
um i just think we're not ready to do
this i think we need to do more research
on how all those cases are handled now
what's the budget for that
and dig down deeper and i think we need
the time for that rather than to start
it
okay um i i just uh
representative erf your hand could you
i'm sorry
i said i didn't know how to wrap you go
ahead and i'll i'll come in after you're
done
you're good go we want to hear what you
say
okay um i uh i guess kathy's more
familiar with the process of course than
i am but her suggestion sounds very
reasonable
to extract that i guess as a retained
bill sort of we can do that out of hp2
i think that's what she's kind of
suggesting and that seems like a
reasonable approach going forward
okay so um i i would just remind people
um
what the administrative cost here is and
and
and whether or not we have the bandwidth
to do it and when i say we i mean the
the royal we of the lba uh we've got
uh mr ripple uh scheduled to be with us
i think on april 12th to deal with the
forensic
hospital but but he's going to be in the
throes of doing this
all this again with the senate and so
there's not a whole lot of bandwidth
that that he's got available to support
us with meetings and
all and so i would just make want to
make sure
that if it's the sense of the committee
that we
do what we're doing with the forensic
hospital that we just do it in light
of the idea that um the lba
is a scarce resource for the next couple
of months and we
need to be careful not to over try to
over commit them
but uh rupper is i don't i don't know
who raised their hand first nordran or
walt walner so um represent nordron
no i just wanted to say i don't think
this needs to be done
at the same time the senate is working
on the budget i think this is something
we can do
later i don't think we need to rush with
it because
i think if we if we make the decision
that there
will be no money allocated for the first
year the biennium i think that's
something we can take our time with
thank you so so just to pursue that
what what is the on off switch for the
second year
i mean just if you imagine that we did
spend time on it
and we and we decided sometime and say
august or something that that the second
year isn't
ready either uh if we put it into hb2
now what is the off switch if if we
if we hit that situation
you know i'll i'll just turn the phone
um well i don't know what the off switch
is i
i mean i really liked kathy's first
proposal of pushing it out
a year um and but getting going i
i'm i'm a little worried that if we
don't have something in the budget if we
don't have something in the budget to
address it it will
um not happen during this biennium
i mean we might have hearings we might
have discussions
but the thought that we're going to be
appropriating money off
in the off-budget year seems unlikely to
me
so to get the so if we
take this out and we don't leave
something in so that they can start
get going in the second year push that
date out a bit
um i i just feel like we're going to
lose the biennium and i think
i i just got i for my for myself i just
got
so concerned about those people i mean i
just had not been aware
that we had 38 people out of state
and um that i really felt like
they would be much better served and
their families would be better served if
they
had opportunities here in new hampshire
to receive their care
and i'd like to see us that part of the
report i really would like to see ask it
going on
and i think the other parts um that they
don't cost a lot they're significant
also um i
i just i'm not sure what the off switch
would be
but i do think that we could it would be
better if we would leave
something in and have it start um maybe
just my thoughts so may i ask you a
question
so i think i think based on what you've
said
maybe uh there's a possibility where you
could be
satisfied with in the second year
because
these this was four group homes i
believe
what what if we were to say in the
second year one group home or two group
homes but not maybe four
you know is there is there another way
to slice this
to space it and and get going but
get going with some um
some training wheels what do you think
about how do you react to that
possibility
um i guess i didn't
he i i'm sorry that i did not
i'm sorry that i did not hear
i didn't hear four i i know you had
referred to it before and i just must
have missed
um in the presentation i must have
missed that it was
four group homes um
for some reason i wrote down actually i
thought it was
actually i thought it was more than that
um
can anyone clarify that data point i i'm
pretty sure it was four i'm like
85 confident whoever
can verify that data point just speak up
because
there are four hands up four is what i
remember down
so representative rogers your hand is up
would you
have something to share i had four
written down but
mr chairman i have a proposal or
proposition for you
would you be willing to give me the
weekend to work with um representative
walner
[Music]
an amendment and kevin ripple amendment
that would um
give us um some starting money but also
incorporated a plan where the um
division would be able to work on what
we want to do the second year so that we
um
we give some startup money for the
second year that would accomplish
enough so we get going but also give the
division
um some capacity to work on it what
what process and how we move forward so
that we don't do
the entire expenditure but we do expend
some part of the money and i would have
a
an amendment um as soon as i get it i'll
forward it to you and then
with your permission if um you want to
we can forward it to the entire division
i'll try to
do it as quickly as i can but i think
it's going to take
talking to all those people to come up
with some of the answers that are being
questioned right now
but i'd be willing to work on that and
try to put it together if you're
willing to allow me that time so
i i love everything he said and i
appreciate it and i want to say yes but
before i say
uh go for it let's let's just touch base
with mr ripple because
we have some timelines here what what
what
what what do you think uh kevin about
us having a proposal over the weekend
and and talking about it on monday and
where where does that take us
i think that would be fine um so i think
i heard you mentioned previously that
you wanted to vote everything out
if not on monday then on tuesday and
that would certainly provide time to
have an amendment by either monday
afternoon or tuesday morning
i guess the only issue is if the
committee decided to revise that
amendment
into something different it might take a
little bit longer
so so with that representative rogers i
i would i'd thank you for
the offer and ask you to make it happen
and and then coordinate it how you see
fit over the weekend so that we can
discuss it on monday
and if i can possibly get it to you and
and mr ripple prior to uh
to monday i will um i will
as quickly as i can so so i
i think i've heard the consensus that
that that the people on this phone call
i haven't actually heard from
representative bean who may have a
different opinion but
that that uh that the consensus seems to
be
that we're okay with the first four
items and the
and what we're really just trying to
figure out is the right way to handle
is that your understanding and and
you're gonna you're gonna have a
proposal that deals with all five of
these
or just just the dd redesign
i'm not sure yet i'm gonna try to see
what makes everyone the happiest
okay
i'm i'm i'm good with that uh
representative wallner your hand is up
okay representative rogers your hand is
still up
oh that's just because i forgot to put
it down sorry okay
i i just you still have a floor if you
want it
um okay so uh let's
if we can can you take us back mr ripple
to the
okay so uh we're sort of
uh tweaking 35 there where
representative rogers
at all will come back and we'll talk
about that some more on monday
uh what's going on with 37
that was the 1.5 million appropriation
that you discussed oh yeah
yeah we deleted that okay uh 38.
this is the one we talked about with the
200 000
yes all right so
i just think it should have already been
in the appropriations bill it should
already be in hb1
and they say that they overlooked it
but if it's an ongoing operation in an
ongoing program
i i don't know how you overlook
something like that so
i i i'm okay with like i could see
accepting 38
and zeroing out the additional money so
that they feel like they've got the
authority to proceed but
they need to figure out the money
because it's an ongoing operation
that's me starting a conversation that's
not my final
thought but but that's kind of what i'm
thinking about that did
any representative earth well
i think we may have left or perhaps
maybe i
may have left it that karen can suggest
the camera might suggest a change
request
for the hb1
i think what karen talked about earlier
was if you were to delete section 38
she would hope for an appropriation in
house bill 1. so they would continue to
get that 200
000 but there would also be a federal
match associated with it
right understood and i believe she also
indicated that she could make a
change request to affect that
yes but i think she's asking for
support for 200 000 more to go into the
general funds
it's not just a change request it's it's
also more money
it's right okay that's certainly true
yes
i think what she requested is the same
amount of money that's currently
budgeted in section 38
this would move it out of hp2 and we'd
need to have an amendment to plus up hb1
by 200 000.
right so that'd be the change request
yes so i'm being parsimonious and
thinking
you don't need another 200 000. figure
out how to get it done
but uh but that's why that's a
conversation point
if i may mr chair i have already done
the change request
for karen to move uh
appropriate that 200 000 into house bill
one
with a seventy five percent match so a
total of
eight hundred thousand six hundred
thousand being federal
two hundred thousand being general funds
i don't know that she had time to
um submit that to mr ripple
that makes it sound like a bargain right
getting 200 you get 800 000 for 200 000
that's pretty great not a bad rate
i'm sorry what's your question would
that be using that ratio could
could we do 50 and get 200 which is what
mary are you comfortable answering that
that's that's a that's a
that's a tough question i would i would
have to check with other folks within
the department before i'd be able to
so if uh mr ripple
assuming you had in your inbox but
you've not looked at it yet
a change request for that to go into hb1
uh is that something that is appropriate
for us to vote on and
and can we vote on that monday if
assuming it's in your inbox
you could i don't have it yet but um if
i could get that then
you could vote on it as soon as i have
it
so mary do you have a thought there
when do you think he'll have it i can
send it over
um immediately i just need to attach it
to the email
so while you're doing that let's come
back to 38 and
what's what i forget what we're doing
with 41.
oh me i keep forgetting what we're doing
with 41 because i dropped the ball again
representative mcguire on what her
reasons were for not
so i apologize to the committee this
one's on me
i messed up and i did ask sorry i did
ask nancy and mike hoffman in division
one if division one had any input into
these sections since they were
originally
assigned to them um and their answer was
no
so this is where i need the the the
elders of the committee to give me a
recommendation
should should we just approve this in
uh section 41 and and
work it in the senate or should we
delete it here
and allow the senate to add it back if
they want
or a third choice
representative wallner you got any
i mean i think that we should leave it
done the work in the budget for this and
what i heard was that that it was all
something that the department and
the licensing people had been working on
for a long time so
i would leave it in if there's problems
with it
i guess people will arrive in the senate
we didn't really have anybody come and
speak against this
no we didn't other than a hallway
conversation i had with
representative mcguire there was no
negative input
and we didn't have any testimony in a
public hearing
it has not had a lot of controversy
so i would leave it in okay i
i'm i i see your point let's let's let's
throw it open is there anyone
in the participants list that wants to
comment
on section 41.
we just lost an attendee so so
i guess they don't want to say all right
uh representative only your hand is up
did you have more
no no that that was it i am going to be
leaving though shortly so
okay yeah so uh i would
but i
i'm fine with that i'm i'm okay with
that
uh recommendation i think i think that's
a fine recommendation
you do you want to make a motion that we
accept section 41 since that's what
we've been doing
sure i'll make a motion that we accept
second
is there any further discussion
not hearing any uh representative bean
are you ready to take a a roll call
yes mr chair representative walner
yes wait a second i i don't are we still
in the
conversation piece of this because you
hit you put your hand up
before he asks you your vote do you have
so
so the motion is on the floor is that
we're about to vote on whether or not
division 3 wants to accept
section 41 of hb2 okay and the motion is
too accepted is that correct
yes sir yes thank you sorry about you
that's all right i'm sorry to interrupt
the vote but i i
i think your hand went up before we
actually took a vote
so so so go ahead and and start your
roll call over again
representative bean okay representative
wallner
yes representative nordwin yes
representative rogers yes representative
yes representative edwards yes
and representative bean would vote yes
uh
representative weiler still absent
so um mr ripple
would you would you uh take us back to
the
yes just one moment
we're about to we're about a few minutes
from
losing some of our committee for a
little while
um so let's just take a look at what we
what we still have to do
one that you could do right now is
section 38 i've gotten the email from
mary
uh so you have the house bill one change
that would accompany that and i also
have an amendment to
delete section 38 from house bill 2 so
you could take care of both sides of
that
if you wanted to so we could go either
way
or we could do both right
okay we could do both so so tell me
what's below
on the second page or third page did you
i think they're only the veterans
sections okay because i thought i had
asked
for the informal uh hb2s to be added to
this list
and you know i forgot i forgot to
include those so that's
but i and the reason i was hoping it
would be there
is so that we can talk about it today to
get a sense
one of them was um
related to the email i sent i got some
feedback from representative rogers
about a proposed change to the way
the forensic hospital was going to look
and she had a couple of
comments for me uh representative walner
uh you know correctly pointed out that
we're planning to discuss it on april
12th
and um and so so
while our colleagues are away
uh the people who remain
could could talk about that proposal
just to share information
um there will be no votes and if we get
through with that conversation
we could just go into recess until four
o'clock if you think that's enough time
we're getting pretty close to being done
anyway so
um so let's go ahead and
and look at the the one or two votes
sure
so i'll show you the house bill one side
so the big one that that didn't get
written there that's the informal one
is the personnel reductions i
wanted i wanted to be able to talk to
people about the potential of that one
and and we really need our full
so this is the change sheet that mary
sent over and uh
if you need if you need a further
explanation perhaps you can speak to
that
so just walk us through what's going on
from the
governor's proposal show us
his general funds request and what the
new
amount would be just to be really
obvious
okay well so for this section i can pull
up the governor's
house bill 2. uh it was a 200 000
general fund appropriation in 22
and i'll bring that up momentarily but
you can see down here
the department is requesting essentially
the same but it includes the
federal funds of six hundred thousand
so i'll bring up the governor now let's
see
and here is the original two hundred
thousand dollar appropriation
yes sir can you do you know where in the
governor's
budget hb1 that the line item is that
we're adding to
account 9540 and
services
so so can you ver just verify for us
that
um this change
is using the proper governor's budget
baseline
yeah i mean normally that's a that we
would just assume that's what happened
but i don't wanna assume
sure
okay so the number we're talking about
right now is 26.070
yes okay so
it should be 26.270 when we go look at
the change request
[Music]
and it's slightly more than that sorry
there's that 804 thing floating in there
that's
inconsequential right is that the actual
number
what's your question representative erf
did she actually because of whatever
she's doing put in two hundred thousand
eight hundred and four dollars it was
804 already there says he's really
adding just a 200
if i may i uh noticed when
preparing this change request that that
804 dollars was budgeted in
error that that agency income will not
actually be received and took the
opportunity to correct that at this time
as well
which is why it's slightly more than the
200 000.
okay but i'm just trying to balance
things for our analysis i should just
use the 200 000 the 804 or something
else altogether
yeah the 804 is not related to the 200
000.
okay and can you tell me what line
number or lump 9 line numbers
so this this would be adding to class
102 in accounting unit 59.52
unfortunately i used a prior change
request and rushed and didn't update all
of the numbers that i should have so my
apologies for that
i will send kevin a corrected one that
will only change the accounting unit
will not change
the actual dollars um but it would be in
class 102
which is contract line let's
let's uh let's wait until you've had the
right time to make sure that you're
uh confident in the product let's not
vote
um we have colleagues that need to get
to another meeting
so um i
actually why don't we just go into
recess until four o'clock
and it may just take a few minutes uh
for us to
wind up but i'm hoping that
representative weiler will show up with
that
uh ways and means update that that would
be worth listening to on a late friday
afternoon
so uh representative erf your hand is up
sir
sorry okay so i i'd like to put us into
mary can i ask how to reach you
sure uh you can reach me um
on 271 9294
in terms of phone right
um and uh my email is
dhhs.nh.gov
all right and how late will you be there
i'm gonna be here until you guys are
done today
okay is there any chance i'll be able to
reach you tomorrow
um you can reach me tomorrow
um if
it would be easier for me if we could
plan a time to meet tomorrow
to meet to either phone or what have you
tomorrow that would be easier for me
than just leaving it open but
if that's what you needed i could give
you my cell phone number
what time is good for you um
probably 10 10 30 i don't know if that
works for you
well me or you want me to call you
whatever is easier for you um i'll call
you at 10 if that works for you
okay okay what number should i call um
where i probably will need uh
information from the computer
um you could call the number i already
gave you
okay great i will give you a call at 10
o'clock in the morning then
okay sounds good i'll catch you tonight
when we
i'll try to call you right when we break
up it's what you know
what i'm going to look for is um you
know rewrite this proposal of the a
m thing is kind of like what pro you
know if we start with a
proposal for the first years what we
want to put in that first
or how much which program so
okay think about now while we're in
recess maybe that'll be good
okay okay thank you thank you
yes i can um you're you're still
recording i don't know that we need to
do that in our recess
all right sure i'll stop all right
thanks
oh since you can still hear me though um
do you do you think you could just in a
real um
slap dash way put
the three or four other hb2 items i
uh sure um let's start the recording you
just did
uh we're back from uh 45 minute recess
uh representative weiler uh welcome back
to division three
thank you could you tell me sir how much
time you have
for this meeting we've got five items
still
and i would just like to know how much
uh
tommy you can share with us so i can
pace us
whatever you need oh okay
um the rest of you more tired than i am
from meeting all day
yeah no we've we've been thriving on
this
so so uh if you wouldn't mind thinking
about
what you can tell us about a ways and
means update we we can come
back to you in a bit unless you're ready
to just speak extemporaneously
whenever you whenever you want i can
give you i can give you the short
version or a longer version
let's hit the short version because i i
among others i think have just been
dying to hear the official update
okay taking into account the tax cuts
that are in hb2
and the new revenue they saw and they
all they met for days on this
they come up with 2022 with an
additional 51.9
million dollars and then in 2023
with an additional 75.8 million dollars
for a total of 127 million
in this biennium over what the governor
had
so this is above the governor's initial
estimate
upon which this revenue upon which this
budget was based
so now there's more revenue
than what we started out with in the
governor's estimate
i anticipating the questions um i think
folks would like to know
what your thoughts are as chair of
finance
about um
you know giving us a target because we
have to
we have to hit a target monday or
tuesday i think or
we it's gonna we're gonna end up with a
number one way or the other
and we're either gonna hit a target or
not what what would you have us do
you think well i think based upon
what we heard in our initial interviews
with the departments and the bureaus and
all that stuff
they're not even up to what was uh
budgeted in 2021 so
to go and build on that is
i think going to be difficult for them
and so
you know i i think we could we could
uh save some money even over what the
governor has
because if we can get a straight answer
from them and see
where the vacancies are and so on and
closing the sununu center yet but sir
we we wanted to have that um with you
returning because i
i came up with some language thinking i
understood what you were thinking
yeah and when i shared it with uh with
mr ripple
um he he he let me know that i i was off
target
and and so uh what i'd like to do sir is
uh
let's we we we forestalled a vote on
section 24
and there's two votes in there there's
uh an hb1 proposal and an hb2
proposal this is the money that's
related to the county cap
yeah and so so we'd like to uh
give you um some background on that and
that's
one of the big ones that we should we
should vote on today i think
is good so um if you could
um mr ripple is it better
let's let's let's start with hb2 and and
then we'll go to hb1
so so i'll summarize this representative
on your behalf if that's okay and then
um
and that way you can correct me if i
make mistakes
okay um
uh and i i realize as i'm looking at
your amendment
i don't know what we're doing with 14
through 18. so that didn't last very
long
would you tell us what uh h what 14
through 18 do again
well let me just tell you what the three
changes so this is the county cap
portion of hp2 representative wyler
and there are three parts to what
used to be a single part previously it
only had the numbers in there and we'll
come to that
bit um now there are uh
three components to it and i've got to
so one of them changes
the order in which the funding streams
are applied and there are three funding
streams
there's the five million dollar general
fund piece that is
in law there's the
uh general fund the the increase of the
general fund that we put in
to bring the county cap down and then
there's the county cap
itself so presently
the two as i understand it and i think i
had this right before karen
i think corrected me slightly in certain
places but i think the general gist of
this is correct
presently the general funds are applied
first
and the county funding
i'm sorry presently i assign it
backwards again presently the county
funding is spent
first and then the general funds are
applied
the effect of that is that if the
expenses are less than that total
essentially the state benefited from
their general funds not being applied
so one of the points of this amendment
is to
change that ordering so the county funds
are applied first
and then the general fund streams are
applied
and part of this and this is all in
discussion with the
department in fact there's probably
still a person from the department here
can speak to this if need be
to the enhanced fmap which is not
how how would the county funding how
would the county homes
capture that and it apparently is
difficult to capture that directly
so this is in some sense a balancing out
of that so that's
part one part two are the numbers
and what we did in the budget which
we've not yet
gotten to but what we're proposing to do
in the budget
is to increase the county cap from the
fy 21 base by two percent
in the fy 23 and by a further two
percent
in fy 24. so those are the numbers that
kevin is showing us now
and then the third part of the of the
amendment
uh puts in an ongoing increase
of two percent per year the county cap
going forward obviously the many effects
of that
but one of the effects of that is that
when the next
biennium comes around and the hhs is
doing their budgeting
their base budgeting will include the
two percent increase to the county cap
as opposed to
the five million dollars that they put
in
now as a default um
no i don't say place holder but as the
default value since that's what's in
statute currently does that summarize it
well enough for you
mr chairman i think it does and then you
you had another discussion i think on
resequencing
how different funds get spent
down first and currently the model is
that the county funds
get spent down first so if they don't
need to spend everything the county is
generally
spent first anyways but they're going to
invert the sequence to where the
county funds would be spent last
meaning that they may get some benefit
if
everything doesn't get spent and there's
less spending than anticipated
is that is that correct yes sir
the figures shown on the screen are in
the ones that are awesome i'm sorry go
ahead so
on line 24 where it says 123 million
point three
yeah that that that was the original
number and
and and based on a couple of things that
uh representative earth did and he's
going to show it to us on hb1
that that number is now 129 million
so is that that's the number the state
is paying not the counties
see that better when we go look at hb1
and
we'll do that before we vote on anything
all right
could i just jump in with one thing
there um yeah the numbers that you see
that
on lines 24 and 25 those original
numbers of 123
and 126.9 those were for the current
2021 biennium
the governor's numbers for 22
were 148.9
and in 23 were again 148.9 so this
amendment brings that
brings those numbers down and this would
be the cap on county contributions this
wouldn't be the state cost
so these are the revised numbers thank
you yes
should i bring up the excel sheet for
your php
and then represent earth do you want to
explain these sure
so first of all there's a change to
the budgeting the expense side the line
number 504
which kevin can highlight the 10 million
dollars
so it's on line 17 of the sheet there
you go um
so based on a again an agreement or an
understanding with the hhs
the original budgeting apparently was
based on a number of
i think we said 4 100 beds and
it seems that a better estimate is 3 900
beds
at the beginning of fy20 or for fy 2022.
so that resulted in a 10 million dollar
reduction in the
in that 504 expense line for flight 2022
and then going forward they do expect
that as we come out of covid
uh the bed count will go back we'll
start back up again
and as patients are readmitted to the
nursing homes
so that reduction in the second year
2023 is
five million dollars and that has the
effect
well of course that lowers the total
costs
of all the lines against which the
county cap applies
which has the effect of on its own
reducing the
county cap so then down below
when we get to the um the county cap
number now the private local funds that
has been
decreased from the
governor's number the 143.9 million
to yield a two percent increase over fy
21 in the county cap so it's it's
getting it down to a value of 124
million
roughly by decreasing the
um private local funds budgeted by about
19.5 million
in fy 2022 and similarly in fy 2023
the county cap increases the further two
percent which is the 126
0.8 million um which results
which causes the uh well which is a
result in it which which is caused by a
reduction in the county cap
of 17 million from the budgeted number
and which increases the general funds
um by that same amount this will be good
news for the meeting that
keith and i have to go to one o'clock on
i hope so so i'm just trying to remember
what was on
the hb2 amendment and i'm seeing 124.3
right and ly 22
does that need to be reflected in hp2
because it seemed like it was a higher
number on hb2 right
because on hb2 the 5 million dollars is
included
it's very confusing you just made it
very simple
so so uh representative erf walked us
through this
and and uh we didn't we didn't really
have much
interactive discussion around it um
uh do you do you have any uh questions
or comments other than the this will be
good news on monday
it'll be good news on monday and we
talked about it through the this week as
well
i was well aware of what he wanted what
his intentions were i just hadn't seen
the exact numbers
but i know what i know what he's doing
here and i see he's accomplished it
thank you very much mr representative
your hand is up yes thank you uh
representative erf as you
uh put all of this together which
thank you for doing all this work um
the counties have been
a part of this of this work and they
they think this is a good way to go
forward yeah that is my understanding
and
in our discussions this morning karen i
pretty sure acknowledge that
perhaps mary can speak to that if need
be
i was not involved in those
conversations so we i think we may have
uh kate horgan on who is
i forget the name of the county
association but if you want to
association with counties you want to
speak to her uh
representative walner with that question
sure i'd like i mean i would
like to hear how they you know how the
counties are feeling about it because
it's a big
it's a big part of county government
hi yes it's kate horgan i'm the
executive director of the new hampshire
association of counties and
representative walner we were
very involved with the construction of
this amendment and we are very happy
with where
where it is and would encourage you all
to adopt it into house bill 2.
are there other questions or
conversation
so um
i i i i would like us to uh
entertain a vote on hb2 as amended
uh for section what is a section
so so right now you're seeing what how
30 wait a second
yes this this amendment would replace
section 24.
i i'll make that motion if you want me
to do you want me to make it in
conjunction with the budget part of two
you have an idea on that mr ripple it
sounds like it can be in one vote
um i would actually recommend two
separate motions since you're amending
both bills okay so i would move that we
accept
amendment number zero eight nine six h
two h b two section
number twenty four
not seeing any discussion uh
representative weiler representative
bean's been filling in for you are
are you ready to take a roll call sir do
you want representative bean to continue
please
representative weiler votes yes
representative bean
yes representative walder
yes
representative rogers yes
representative edwards yes
so so on a seven to nothing vote
uh the the motion passes and we will
replace section 24.
so let's go back to the spreadsheet and
mr ripple re remind remind us of exactly
what we're able to vote on and what
we're not this is
this is a is this an official change
request is this
a spreadsheet that will become a change
request what
what what's our status here you can
consider this even though it has no
amendment number
attached to it you can consider this an
official house bill one amendment
so you could uh vote to make these
changes to accounting unit
is there a motion to
change
i would make a motion to adopt the
changes to county unit 2152
do i need to reference a number kevin or
something or just as seen on the
spreadsheet
i'll second yes
saying um uh mr clerk would you take a
role please
representative earth yes representative
weiler votes yes
representative bean yes
yes
7-0 thank you 7-0 the motion passes so
um we can go on to the next issue
uh mr ripple my memory is horrible what
did we do with section 38 the
200 000 that was for the adt
transfers did we vote on that you
haven't acted on that yet
a new excel spreadsheet from
mary kalis let me just find that because
and you already had an amendment to to
delete
well in this case let's look at the hb1
miss please do you do you want us to
explain this or
or would you like mr ripple to we'll go
kevin i believe that's the original one
is this theory it does look like the
original bosnia it is the original one
did i not send you the revised one i i
think you did let me just uh make sure i
have the right one
uh oh actually that was the one the one
that i just opened was the most recent
actually
so i might suggest postponing this one
until
monday you could still vote on hb2
though
and and and then over the weekend you
kind of know what we're doing and it'd
be easy to integrate our vote i think
okay so let's let's go to
okay and this would simply delete the
delete that section and the
appropriation contained in it
right so so since this is so simple
can you pull up 38 so we can all
remember and
uh representative weiler wasn't with us
earlier so he probably needs to see it
again
so representative weiler we we had
mr david wetter's in here
uh this morning uh and uh
we got more detail about this 200
000 it it it is an ongoing program
they did uh overlook uh including in an
hb1
this 200 000 that is an hb 2
uh would be good to uh earn a federal
match
so this two hundred thousand gets
matched by another six hundred thousand
and so that's eight hundred thousand
dollars that comes
in on a revenue line if we accept the
idea
uh and that eight hundred thousand
dollars is going to
uh a contractor who's meaning
maintaining
the basically the architecture
that's uh sending out
something called an administ admissions
discharges and transfers message
to receiving systems that have
interfaces and so it's a it's an
important
aspect of the way that care is getting
coordinated
between the state and the communities
and between communities
and so there they have a plan to
expand the number of clinical users in
the communities
and so um so the idea though
is because it's an ongoing program it
was really in hb2
uh to make sure that uh even though
they'd forgotten the budget
that it got added back and while adding
it back
uh there was a recognition that some
federal money would come along with it
six hundred thousand
so um so the idea became
in our discussion well why don't we just
go ahead
and delete section 38 because
it's this is already ongoing operations
it's an
ongoing program and and and to bring it
over into hb1
um as a as a net increase
so so that's that's what we discussed
earlier i think
uh um ms khalis steve do you
did i do you think i said that right do
you want to change anything i said
no i think your description of that was
representative irf i still have a
question as to whether they need
two hundred thousand dollars as a
request for an hb2 or eight hundred
thousand dollars as
which they get once they match it with
the six hundred thousand dollars of
federal funds
uh if i'm a representative i was able to
uh speak
with henry lipman the director of
medicaid services and he did confirm
that we do need the 200
000.
may i follow him yes um
i guess my question is what about the
well we can get federal match for the
so i think what representative irf is
asking is this really an
eight hundred 800 000 project there's a
number less than that i mean just
because we can get federal money
that is my understanding from the
okay first do you have a follow-up well
i'm just i would just
i mean no but i would suggest that i'm a
little bit confused by that because it
seems like
if that's the match ratio you could we
could do 50 000 general funds
get the 150 match and have the 200 000
that they want
that's really what my underlying
question is
[Music]
thank you great and i i think the answer
back from ms police is that it's
it is in fact an 800 000 project and the
200 000
is needed to get the match to support
the total project
and that this money is going to a vendor
who's maintaining the architecture and
doing the updates
and expansions
maybe she could just speak to confirm
that that they really were
once 200 000 was in hb2 they would have
been able to match it
i would think that if the 200 000 was
budgeted
um in-house bill 2 for us to uh add the
federal we would have had to go to
thank you you have any questions uh
representative weiler you're you're
you're you're sort of seeing this kind
of this detail for the first time oh i
think i think keith was right we got to
show those 800 000 and that's the way
it's
it makes some shortcuts we have any
other
conversation around this um
i i don't think we're ready to vote on
the spreadsheet
because mr ripple and miss police just
want to make sure that
we're voting on the right spreadsheet
but
okay do you have the
back to the amendment that's just simply
deletes the section 38
right
okay so i would entertain a motion
on on this uh bill this amendment
i make a motion to accept amendment
number zero
nine zero two h to amend
is there further conversation about
i'm not do you have a question or a
conversation
uh representative walner i see your you
got your pin pointing at us
no i don't thank you all right
so um uh mr clerk would you take a roll
please
representative earth yes representative
weiler votes yes
representative bean yes representative
walnut
yes representative nordgren
yes representative rogers yes
representative edwards yes seven to zero
is the most
okay um
all right so uh i
before i move on to the next topic mr
ripple is it's still the case that you
and miss
please have a little more coordination
to do
i have the most recent i have the most
recent spreadsheet now so i think you
should be able to vote on that
okay um and and for your benefit
uh representative weiler that that 804
000 decrement in there for agency income
we asked about that earlier and and that
was a
a a small mistake in the draft process
that ms klisch recognized and
is taking the opportunity to just fix it
at the same time
yes so so far this afternoon
um i've noticed that we've been adding
back
uh expenses to that back um
appropriations to the budget this is the
second one i mean obviously we just did
the county one
um i assume these are coming out of the
found 127.7 million dollars that
the chairman just spoke to us about and
i guess
the hesitancy i have about voting even
for this 200
um and i did i did vote for the county
cap because
i obviously um have been concerned about
that right along but i
my hesitancy is here's 200 000
and it's going to get the first
it's getting the first decision of house
bill one
how to spend this found money
and i i mean i guess i need to stack it
up
against something else that might cost
200 million dollars that someone might
and that's that's sort of the dilemma
i'm in we're now
we're adding back money into the budget
but we're doing it we're doing them in
isolation i haven't seen house bill one
i haven't seen what we're doing as a
total in house bill one
am i making myself clear is that oh i
think so
uh subsystem optimization was the word
they taught me in grad school
wow i've never heard that word before
yeah well that's where i went to grad
school
so so if you if you would be more
comfortable
holding off the vote on this hb1 change
until monday i i i
i think i would be fine with that uh our
goal
is is to lay out
a view of hb1 of the amendment
i would i would appreciate that because
i would like to see
i would like to see the full picture um
before i am i have already voted for the
county cap
um so i would like to see
a whole picture of how much money we are
adding back
into the bus budget and where
i think that's a reasonable request and
and i i can hold off a vote until monday
yes okay did you say
something to representative weiler did
you say yes i think yes i have
further discussion okay what would go go
for it
okay she's saying we're adding this back
in of 127
million have you decided earlier in the
day
to go with what the governor had in this
in this budget or if you're still
working from representative earth's
working papers
where we cut uh quite a bit of money out
of the
um hb1 hhs budget
have you added that all back everything
that that we
that representative thing took out if
that's the case
then we are adding new money but if we
if we're just still working from where
we started with a
big deduction then we're just still
adding back money that we had took it
away early
yeah so i think um technically the
the correct answer is that until we
got a ways and means update uh we were
on the same trajectory that we've been
on for the last week or two
assuming the ways and means estimate was
was the gold standard well i was
i was uh misled when she said we're
adding back money from 127 million
because we still have started from a
different place
than the governor was if i'm
yes sir to be fair we really hadn't i
hadn't
uh clarified that uh in the morning i i
we've just been holding off for a ways
and means update and
i've just assumed that until we know
otherwise we
continue to do what we're doing unless
we know better
there was also some thought at the
meeting i was out of
speeding up some tax cuts and using some
of the money that way so
um you know we'd be cautious about
adding
anything back some of the things we've
deducted already and and representative
earth found
places in the budget that the governor
had spent less
than what the uh agency had put in so
until we add it all up i don't know as
we're adding more money to this budget
as it came to us or
still spending less thank you
yes sir and while you're away one of the
things that we
we did uh and we voted on and turned out
to be six to nothing so i
i didn't mind voting in your absence was
um
we we agreed that the department
would use the same enhanced fmap
process or estimates that they had used
for the primary medicaid account
and by using that same assumption on
other
medicaid accounts it added back
um or it was basically found money of
about 12.5 million
so so even on the same trajectory we
were on with ways and means earlier
today we did
but um but but i think i think we're all
saying the same thing that we shouldn't
vote on this one
item until we see the whole picture on
monday
representative wallner i didn't mean to
interrupt you did you no no no
thank you that that was exactly my point
um we have already we have already done
that with the county cap
um but like you said we did have 12
million dollars
um additional this morning so
um you know that comes into the picture
too
maybe that off maybe that balance maybe
that helps balance out part of the
okay so i think we have three more
things to talk about
i would like to talk about the sununu
youth center and some
some potential language questions like
to talk about
pardon me lots of hands lots of hands
representative nordgren question or
comment
thank you very much um i guess
my question i tend to be very
organized and like to know the plan so
i'm just wondering if you could maybe
tell us what your plan is for monday and
tuesday so we
sort of have an idea of your agenda both
days
that would be helpful thanks okay so
just
just to make sure that we're coming off
of the same base
do you recall receiving my copies of the
division three march
madness the calendar that shows
the plan for monday um
and i didn't i received the second page
okay um the the first edition had
everything
the the i've i've sent some images
of snips twice
but any case uh monday to answer your
question
is uh it's it's on the house calendar is
a as a work session
uh i'm um i've got it down that we're
gonna
i'm not sure if that's the right term
for us but we're going to exact
hp 254 hb 600
um i've got
section 19 hanging out there and we're
going to have to add
section 34
to a discussion and maybe a vote on
monday
so sections 19 and 34
are still outstanding i think
we're going to have an hb1 discussion in
votes and we're going to have an hb2
discussion in votes
so the idea on the hb1 and 2
uh and and this is this is where i don't
want to over commit mr ripple and i also
want to admit i'm not
exactly sure what this thing look is
going to look like
but i'm i'm thinking that we may have
something to review on monday that looks
like
division three's hb1
amendment proposal and that we can
review it
and look at the big picture and and see
where all the moving parts are
that that's that's for monday and then
i have intentionally left tuesday
and wednesday unscheduled
in case we have crises and we need
we need to just push it you know keep
keep working for another day or two
but if everything goes great we could
potentially be done monday
or tuesday does that
does that answer your question yeah
thank you and maybe
if representative weiler has any updates
on when he's going to do the
budget briefing that would be helpful
that determine representative weiler how
we're going to do the budget briefing to
the house
thank you for the question uh
preliminarily with the speaker
you know we're having a three-day
session on uh
seven eight and nine he's gotta make
some arrangements but we tentatively
talked about the sixth of
the uh tuesday before the three-day
session so it'll be
four-day four-day session
so it wouldn't be a zoom it would be an
in person
reaping on the ship yeah
at the sports arena very likely
yes really well i i don't think they can
do a 400 person zoom yet
no i don't think i think they can excuse
me
so so that's outside of our divisions
responsibility well so however
however he does it it'll likely to be
so representative wallner your hand is
up well i
also wanted to ask um chairman weiler if
um what day he thinks we will exec
the full committee will exact house bill
one and two
the 25th of march
i better get those to janet so they can
make sure i make the calendar
representative if your hand is up oh i'm
sorry go ahead representative
isn't isn't the 25th of march
next week yeah yes
wouldn't we have had to be in this
trying to remember if i told her to put
it in there i i read that you got this
week
yeah i didn't see it in there that's why
okay so it would be in house calendar 16
which is the most current yeah last
night but i didn't
all right so so if you can
mr ripple since you're so facile would
you
bring up house calendar 16 and take us
to
march 20 25th
25th i can do that i'll pull it up now i
did confirm i looked through it last
night and i did not see a full committee
exec session schedule but i'll pull it
there are currently division two and
three work sessions scheduled but no
full committee exec
sorry about that i guess at the time i
i think division one is finished but the
other two hadn't given me definite
my apology i i i've been trying to say
the 24th of march
is when we're our our internal drop dead
date kevin what date were you on
it was let me bring it back up
there's a new calendar out isn't it
never mind yep that's the most recent
one that just came out last night
yeah yeah so i could i could put it in
the
calendar on
friday the 26th
because as you note the calendar will
show the friday
yeah that's right it will all right so
we agree in this in this division and i
get the other divisions to agree as well
because i see karen had
something on the 25th so i can tell you
that
i'm i'm thinking our work will be done
by then sir
all right so let's say we'll exec on the
26th which is a deadline and i can still
make it
into the calendar for next thursday
representative walter your hand is still
up yeah oh i'm sorry i'm sorry
thank you thank you sorry representative
thank you mr chairman i just wanted to
regarding uh representatives comments
about the
what we're voting on we already have
voted on five of the different
accounts have a four or five or some
number a couple days ago
are we still waiting to vote on those
coming up i think it was like disability
and medicare and medicare
whole exact session on friday
those let me try to answer that when
when we voted the 51 million ad back
for the medicaid and then you know 17
million for something else
though those those were uh
to build our increment list
to where that that wasn't votes
to to definitively put it in hb one
no that's fine so we did i don't
recognize we did vote on that right
that's all we had votes
and from my perspective what we were
voting on was
our our increment list
which also works as a decrement list if
we were to take
a cut so that's what i thought we were
doing
okay so i still would like to to
introduce
a conversation on uh the sununu youth
center
a personnel hb2 and um
and just flash the forensic hospital
right up
uh to make that's in your inbox but i
wanted to just get synced on on what i
think we're doing with that
so so um mr ripple could you show
that intent language i put together on
sysc
please
so so representative weiler we were
talking
gosh i don't know when that was was that
just yesterday maybe
and what i thought i heard you tell me
was that we wanted to um
put something into hb2 dealing with
our thoughts around closure of the
sununu center
so i drafted this language which
subsequently
i ended up missing the that meeting with
mr dejoy
due to the my car clock being wrong
um but so so mr ripple
has talked to mr dejoy mr dejoy
i think was under the impression that
our language coming out of our division
would be that we would shut the sununu
center
at the end of this by by the end of this
biennium
and and when i had considered this
language
that just felt to me too quick so this
that's why i wrote
it this way and and
um i don't know that we have language to
review from mr
joy today but but i thought i would at
least show you
what i had been thinking uh and then you
can tell me
you know forget this and we're going to
go a different way
and this is the first well i although i
emailed it
to a copy to you this is probably the
first time you've had a chance to
can anyone hear me yeah i had it muted
sorry
oh okay sorry um my discussion with him
was
we think we can give them one year
so it would be at the end of of uh 2022
which would be uh june of
june 30th 2022 rather than 2025
you know and because it just keeps
dragging on and
at the fiscal report we looked at we
looked at that
earlier today there's a an audit out
which doesn't speak very well about the
synonymous senate it's
it's been released uh representative
walmart i think has a copy
and i probably uh you do as well of the
of the audit and that along with
um you know the the uh what i read in
the alvarez and marcel
report uh it's just going downhill fast
over there and so
john dejoy felt that there was a
possibility of getting it done
within a year once we passed this budget
they've got a year
and he says most of the uh one of his
ideas was most of the
people there can go into alternativeness
there's some that
need a little more security than others
and that can be done
in in a form that's done over in orford
at the beckett uh company or beckett
organization
and then if we put out a bid
to the county jails most of which have
room
and sometimes an extra wing almost
that the one or two or three murderers
that we can't let out can be isolated in
a
jail and you know there's enough distant
learning now and so on they can be given
they can be given education that way and
uh
you know people can visit them as
psychiatrists or whatever
but it is likely these people will age
out of the juvenile system and go right
into the
mature prison so
i don't think there's any thought to let
them out so we don't need to go to any
halfway house for them but
there's so few of them that
if we put out if we put out a rfp to all
the counties
i'm sure one would one or two would bid
on it
uh i know rockingham county has extra
space so
that that would be the way to deal with
with the handful
of murderers and uh
the rest could be dealt with with less
thing and then we would
uh close the place down and there's some
thought to
either put it on the market or repurpose
it somehow
and one of the things he mentioned was
in the state of new york cuomo went to a
prison that was set up for
youthful offenders there were 200
employees
there was this special prison with no
one
in it and again
he was more worried about employing of
200 people elsewhere in the state
government so another thing that
was uh brought up by mr
de joy is that
if biden is out to forgive
monies that the the federal government
put up to build youthful prisons with
the idea that we need to
we don't want to keep the youthful
prisons going just so we
they don't have to pay us back we'll
forgive the debt
which would would be a big help if we
didn't have to pay
10 million back if we close it and stop
using it or we try to repurpose it
we try to sell it so that's a
possibility as well he felt
strongly so he thought we could save 10
million within this biennium
if we have it closed by the second year
of the biennium
and it and with the talk we had i'm
sorry you missed it it went on for about
an hour
made a lot of sense and he had numbers
and he showed me a spreadsheet
so i was hoping that uh he would get
together with mr ripple and we'd have an
amendment
has he contacted you mr ripple
yes he has i heard from him this morning
and he sent me a few
i think it would be multiple amendments
and he sent me a few of those sections
okay so we could we could put them in my
name
and present them because i have i've
discussed
it with him and and told them that i
approve them and if he would send you
the language
which i looked at that i would be happy
okay so so one task is the language you
see now
this this doesn't appear to provide any
usefulness that we should just get rid
of this language
yeah it it would be like like mr ripple
said it'd be multiple
amendments
so i was hoping that somewhere in there
we could say that the grounds will be
repurposed to provide an ongoing tax
stream to the city and state
and potentially a one-time revenue
stream as well
well i think that's a good intent but i
don't know
yeah we could put it in there it's it's
like ten years ago i think
uh representative walden representative
northern probably remember ten
ten it was maybe 15 years ago we put
laconia in
with similar language and here we are
so i guess it doesn't matter if we have
it in there and it doesn't so it doesn't
matter
okay so mr ripple we we can just uh
we can just trash this language
so um representative edwards
yes this is mary jane um
i certainly agree with the things that
um
chairman weiler just um spoke about
i've been here for a long time and we've
been working on this sununu issue
for a number of years um
and it feels like we're going to have to
set
some pretty aggressive deadlines
or it's not going to happen yep it just
drags
um and it i think it's finally going to
take someone saying
this is the date we've got to work
towards
this date and we have to have it done
i guess the last several times i mean
i've been on a number of bills
amendments everything imaginable and i
i guess in some ways i guess we were
just sort of like too nice
because we never actually said this is
the deadline
and i think that i think that time
that time has come yeah so just so you
know i i think experience is the best
teacher and so i appreciate you sharing
your experience with me
on that um the the reason i was hesitant
to go with a
quicker timeline is because i've heard a
lot of concepts from
some really smart dedicated people on
what's going to happen to the kids that
don't need to be
in the sununu center if we like for
example if we were
to agree to hb254 there's
there's a there's a demographic a set of
demographics of people that would no
longer
go to the sununu center they would go
somewhere else well
so far the somewhere else sounds like
concepts that that people haven't
turned into capabilities yet and i don't
i haven't
seen a plan to go from concepts to
capabilities
and and so i'm just reluctant as a
planner
to say okay all the kids out of the
sununu center on this date
without first knowing that there's a
place for them to go
and and if and and and if
and if it's just one of those chicken
and egg things where there's never going
to be a place for them to go until we
say they gotta leave
yeah then okay i can buy that but but
that's
that that's why i went with the later
date
i do think that the system of care that
we started developing in the last budget
is going is already working on providing
a number of those kinds of
of places that in a number of programs
i mean there there's a lot of things
going on around the country
um around keeping kids at home and being
able to send
services into families and trying to
keep
kids in the place where we probably all
agree they should be
and helping families take care of their
own their own kids so
there's all kinds of things going on and
i think
our since our numbers have gotten so low
we should be able to put this together
in a year and have a pretty good plan
and i think that
um i saw uh represent senator
john dejoyce he was a representative at
one point i
saw his um suggestion about the idea of
the county jails for those very serious
offenders um the youth would have to be
separated obviously from the adults
um but that was a suggestion i had not
seen before and i think it was
really had some merit um it would be an
interesting because
those those young people were tried as
adults and were probably
well will definitely go into the adult
system when they turn 18.
and i think kathy can probably tell me
if i'm right or not
because she's an attorney right she
used to work in this she works in this
field for a long time
so uh representative nordron
thank you very much um and i was
thinking when we have this discussion
we should make sure that maura the
child advocate is invited so she
couldn't come and participate
um i don't know what the discussions
have been with
but i think it'd be important to include
her when we have that on our agenda
thanks i agree i agree
um okay so let's let's talk practicality
here for a second
mr ripple um given where you're at and
what you have
when do you see the best case and worst
case
for having hb2 language for us to look
at
well i have informal language that's
been sent to me by
mr dejoy and he's about to send me three
more pieces
um i could
share that with the committee if if you
all would like me to
as far as formal amendments from ols i
think we would end up giving it to them
on monday morning and hopefully would
have everything back by monday afternoon
i'll defer to representative weiler on
the sharing of mr de joy's documents
i welcome it does that mean that we
should put it on the uh
lba website because because i think
that's a related
question well i don't
you know until it's informal language i
don't know is it
you know it's just a preliminary thing
once we have a formal
amendment would be more appropriate
but you know we could be an announcement
to look at
you agree with that mr ripple based on
i i think it will be okay since the the
content that these amendments haven't
been discussed publicly or
anything like that i think it would be
fine to wait until we have a formal
ols amendment all right thank you
so so so the game plan is to send them
to the committee
and and you'll start sending them off to
ols and hopefully we could know by
monday afternoon that's the best case
what do you think the worst case is
tuesday
well i think if you i think if you're in
agreement as to the language you want on
monday morning
then the worst case scenario probably is
tuesday
let's let's use sysc first thing
that we do i had put hb 254 as the first
thing
maybe we'd need to do 254 first and then
and then do syst
yes yes ma'am mr chair um
254 actually
will have a lot it will be need to be
the language there is going to need to
probably i assume would have to be
incorporated
into um the sununu amendment
right um that that's a
that's an integral part of of making
this
work so i i think you're right
and i think when i sat down last night
trying to do that myself i didn't know
how to do that
so that that's why i wrote that little
intent paragraph instead
but uh so so mr ripple are you are you
also
thinking that the two the key sections
of the 254 language
need to find themselves into hp this hp2
language
i don't know that they need to they
certainly could and i believe that may
be part of the
language that mr dejoy is going to
provide
all right mr representative weiler one
of his suggestions was
incorporate 254 and hb2 the language of
it and then
retain 254 so if something happens in
the process
we'd still have that option to do
something with 254.
i think if we incorporate it in hb 2
then when we come to the time for retain
bills we probably won't have to do
anything with it
assuming everything works the way we
hope
and i think it's it's all of us support
it
so i think at this point we have a game
plan are there any questions about what
we're
trying to do over the weekend
on monday i'm not seeing any
so there's two other topics uh and
i i think we just need another 15
minutes and we can adjourn it's been a
long day
um can you show the personnel
uh paragraph that uh that you've drafted
sure
why don't you talk us through this or
maybe people just can read it for
30 seconds and then you can talk us
and i think most of you have read it and
i i just would want to
uh immediately just point out that the
100 and the 10 million
are are still in flux they're they're
tbd's
um i i didn't know what kind of uh
guidance we were going to get coming
coming down
so so so this was an area where i
thought
we might have a shock absorber depending
on what we heard
so that i think all the language here
is is is pretty useful but the hundred
and the
ten million i think are still tbd
uh do you want to do you want to speak
to this now
mr ripple or did i just steal your
thunder no i i think you summarized
everything it's a 10 million dollar back
of the budget production that's
specific to personnel costs um
just to explain how the 10 million
dollars was arrived at
each on average positions in the
department
cost about 50 000 in general funds uh
between salary and benefits
it's an approximate number but i believe
it is pretty close and
lastly there's a fiscal reporting
requirement contained in here as well so
the department would need to come into
fiscal and identify
specifically where they've made those
reductions
so now that i've just heard you say that
my question is
is is this um is there any sort of
i i hate to use the word enforcement in
this context but that's kind of where
i'm going is
what if they don't report what happens
they will i don't need to worry about
that it's not only a reporting
requirement they also need to provide to
das
the exact accounting units and class
lines to be reduced and the section will
have the force of law so it will require
them to reduce personnel related class
lines by this 10 million dollars so
everything contained in here has the
force of law so i'm i'm assuming the
department will
is there a conversation questions
i'm not seeing any yeah yeah
do you have a question uh representative
weiler
just to comment that this is not
untypical of what
all of us have seen before dealing with
hhs
more than any other department this is a
typical thing
when we get done with the other uh
sununu youth center
it may incorporate retraining
and and so on and relocation even for
the employees but that will be over and
above
this and that will begin only happen
when the
sununu center is closed because i think
they've got the about 200 employees
there and many of them
they want to go to work in in one of the
like the glen hill or the
new hampshire hospital where they're
having trouble finding people
so and if if they needed retraining or
go back to school we might even work out
something in the
in the budget of closing the sununu
youth center i think there is something
in the amendment
to do all of that so but this is not
untypical of what we've done in the past
with hhs and
putting it back in the budget cut so
they know how to deal with it thank you
yes sir i i think as far as numbers as i
recall the sununu center
for some reason 116 is in my head
of how many uh authorizations they have
and
i could have sworn that whenever they
talked to us they were talking about 96
people so
i think you're right i think it's i
any any 90s questions comments
so so i think we'll go to another place
then
what's if you would pull up my language
on the forensic hospital
and then representative rogers i'm going
to ask you to
repeat for the public and the committee
your your two
i sent this late last night and it was
uh
uh i don't know if everyone's had a
chance to look at it i've gotten
confirmation from representative rogers
and representative walner that they both
looked at it and then
representative rogers do you want to do
you want to make your observations
sure let me just go back and look at
them again now
basically the first one was related to
the first bullet
about uh you you prefer different
language to the town or municipal
museum municipalities and this is comes
from
experience being from concord and having
served on the council
is that um instead of just saying
municipal involvement
i would like to say that um i would like
to say that that it would be
coordination
um so that instead of just having them
talk to someone
in the public works department or
something like that that they actually
do talk
to the the city or town manager or uh
the chairman of the select board or the
mayor
that kind of thing so that they're
they're talking to somebody in charge of
the municipality
and not talking to just one department
head so
quite often if you talk to a department
head or a department employee it doesn't
work its way up
to the mayor and the city council and so
you don't get the policy leaders there
talking about it
so i just wanted to make that language
maybe say um
coordination or something or direct them
towards the policy leaders
and then the other thing is is i was
just wondering if we could
also ask for operational costs or an
operational plan because
where the the the project isn't going to
go
into operation in the time frame of this
i think that one of the questions we all
had this time around
and two years ago was um what what is
the operational plan of this facility
and what are the costs going to be
because that's obviously something that
while at night that's going into effect
now it will be in effect in the next
budget
and is obviously a concern we have
because you don't operate a 60-bed
facility with no people
and if we have one amendment someplace
else in house bill one or two
it's going to be cutting a hundred staff
people and then we have this
how many staff people are we adding to
in fact make this operational
i think we we should have the right hand
knowing what the left hand is doing
um so i would like us to have something
in here asking for when
they the various information is gathered
that at least
we are shown that they're thinking about
an operational plan for this
may i respond sure okay
so so once again i find ourselves in
violent agreement with one another
oh my god first the first bullet
the the first bullet was my uh
late night attempt to to to get the
coordination and that you had mentioned
and
and so uh so i think that first bullets
just
uh begging to be um edited uh to your
liking uh and then the last bullet on
cost estimates will be included with a
target being plus or minus 15
that that sort of was again my attempt
to
to get it what you're saying that we
need to understand what the annual
operational costs are are going to be so
so that's that's another place where
you're i think
your thoughts find a
foothold and we can just find the right
words there
i do have to say say that i did start
out by
email and return to you saying that i
thought it was a superb plan
and i was thanking you for doing it so i
do you
do that i i was going i was thinking
about making you say it publicly but
well i should have i'm saying it now i i
do think it's a great start plan and
thank you very much for doing it you're
very welcome
um so representative weiler you've had
you had your hand up
and it's down now did you have a
question or comment well i was going to
ask
i was going to ask representative rogers
i'm pretty sure concord has
cities uh water and city sewer
is that true yes it is so that would
that would be a big
deal to be adding a 60-bed hospital
where there's nothing now unless they
knock down some other buildings
but i'm sure that's you know that that
might have to go into the planning there
might have to be additions or
a bigger water main or something like
that so that's the kind of thing why you
got to get involved with
municipality because you just can't
throw it up and then discover you don't
have enough water or enough sewage
so right those are those are important
considerations to be looked at
and get some idea of the flow and so on
so i just
you know i i don't understand what
it just it just means we couldn't agree
any more completely
all right but i guess i'm also in
okay i'll uh and and then uh
representative wallard had emailed me
separately as well
and i think uh one of the takeaways i
got from her
email was uh
an opportunity to remind everyone that
we're anticipating getting a hearing
together
on the 12th of april and
uh with the point of talking about um
this issue and so if we if we kind of
like where this is going
then i would start to encourage people
to think about
who we might want to invite to get them
to our hearing on the 12th of april
so um and and who knows after we hear
from people we might just
throw this out and start fresh but but
um all right uh representative waller
did you have more to add
i'm just a little i'm a little concerned
about
um some of this
i i want to be sure that we hear from
as you know this is sort of something i
always go to but
i want to be sure we hear from people
other than the department
i mean i think we pretty much know where
the department stands
i mean they want a 60-bed they want a
60-bed facility um
i would i'm really
wanting to know what would be
a right size facility
and i'm not sure that i'm going i'm not
sure that
the department is the is the place where
i'm going to find that out
so um
you know if you i think this is this is
fine
um but i i really really want to hear
what um what others think
i mean remember last two years ago this
was a big
issue in the budget and we we ended up
in the budget
passing something that said a 25 bed
facility
yes ma'am and then in the senate
156 also says a 25
bed facility so
um i'm i'm concerned about
jumping right to the 60 bed facility and
they
that we know that's what the department
wants at this point i'd like to hear
other opinions so
i really need more input than just the
department so
thank you so i i would just want to draw
your attention
to the places in this document where
it's uh i've used the phrase 60 beds
and and all of them are qualified with
the term not to exceed
60 beds and you know and
and we're asking them to do research and
report
and so so part of that i've i've tried
to anticipate
that maybe if they really think about it
and start coming up with costs
and coming up with project plans maybe
they'll want to come back and say ah
25 was the right number so so that's
that's why i put a not to exceed into
this document
thank you yes ma'am uh
representative nordgren you had your
hand up for a moment
i do um so i was just going to suggest
i don't know where the senate will be in
their discussions
if they already will have started
looking at the budget but
it might be good to have somebody from
the senate finance committee come and
join
us for the 12th if there anyone's
yes and then i think if um
i think sort of to to that point if uh
where i've talked about the distribution
of the report
uh i i i made it up i said on the house
and senate respectively
you're gonna need uh the report to go to
hhs
ea public works and finance
and and i and i think those are the same
committees
that we should try to involve on the
12th
so um are there any other
comments or questions you take a look at
it the whole point of this document was
really
just to just to try to capture what i
thought i was hearing people
saying and thinking and and um
so that we have some some way to focus
what we're doing on the 12th
so um there's there's really no action
on this other than
if you if you think about it some more
and you want to send
me some replacement words or some
additional words i'd love that
i i want to come back to just one more
thing
did mr ripple did we did we what did we
that was the laconia school was that in
our purview or out
sorry i was muted that's that was
assigned to division one
okay it's out all right so i think
um i think we did a lot today um
did we forget something mr ripple on the
i don't think so you've done everything
okay well it's been a long day and and
people have been really
um great so so thank you i
i think it people not been so great we'd
we'd be here until 10 o'clock so
enjoy your friday evening um
any are there any parting comments for
the good of the committee
sorry i missed so much oh you were busy
you brought in some some great
information well
okay so on that point will we be getting
something in writing
or or or and i forget what you said
about whether or not we were going to
have a target
it doesn't look like it now with this
okay so
all right well thank you thank you go
ahead
yes ma'am go ahead well
what does that mean it i mean i realize
you probably won't
need to make the reductions that you had
had
had to previously because you filled in
the hole that was in between the
ways and means estimates and the
governor's estimate
but will division three be given
um a number of
new money that they can add to the
budget the governor gave us that list of
his
other priorities or um
[Music]
well from the chairman of the committee
yes you won't be given a target but i
still think
that from our interviews with the
department heads and bureau chiefs and
all those that
they cannot get up to what the 2021
budget was
so rather than have them have a lot of
money that probably is just going to
not be spent and relapse because i think
from something the governor said the
other day
the lapses which were expected to be 76
million
from this fiscal year may well go to
150 million so
and a lot of that is from hhs because
they just couldn't expand that fast so
rather than
have them struggle to expand in these
new areas
i i support this back of the budget cut
because and you know we we can restore
much of it but if
if we knew more of the of the vacancies
and where they're having trouble filling
agencies and bureaus
i would cut back the money to those
places rather than have them struggle to
find
people and then have it only half filled
and still not doing half the job they
they don't have enough people to do so
i'd rather still stifle it a little bit
from from the growth because i think the
growth has naturally been stifled just
because of the lack of available people
so rather tie up money there that will
likely lapse
i would still like to see us reduce that
budget a little bit
but not as much as we originally started
out so
if we all look at there and see what the
departments are and go back to uh
representative earth's
figures we might still find agencies
that
don't need as much money as as was put
in there because i don't think they can
spend it and the ones that have been
newly created
without statutory authority i'm i'm a
little bit wary of of them just deciding
what they think they need and just
putting money in it rather than
looking for statutory authority so
i was not impressed with that i guess
they called it the health equity which
would have been refugee
i didn't think we had that bigger
refugee population that we needed to
spend so much money on it so
those are things i'm wondering about but
you know
anything you know when we get together
and discuss it
great but you would probably find
some of the things i found that you know
they couldn't they couldn't expand as
fast as 24
in one year so it's almost wasteful
spending
so a question i would have then um
if we are not if we're not going to be
spending
more in the budget um
and and filling in up to the governor's
level
or doing some of the other things that
he brought in as his priorities
if we're not going to be doing that but
we have x this new revenue
how would we when will we see how that
new revenue would be
would be um proposed to be used
well that's that's some of the
discussions we had today
with the speaker the majority leader and
you know what what can we do to convince
people
to pass this budget and you know
most of them are not impressed with
these
new programs at hhs they're more
impressed with
what can we do to help property taxes
and that sort of thing so
some of the money may go that way but
we've got to figure out what
what's going to appeal to the widest
audience that they would vote for a
budget
and one of the kind of things that you
and i have seen through the years that
people are demanding
like i went and looked at revenue
sharing and realized
that was very outdated legislation
it and it has been suspended every year
since 99
and most of the most of the the revenue
sharing stuff was written in 1970
and it talked about taxes sharing
portions of taxes like the
taxes that have long since disappeared
um you know things like uh
stock you know where you put
put taxes on the stuff in stock and
trade and that kind of thing
i read these taxes that were going to be
shared in 1970 and they
none of them exist anymore so i thought
but so
i guess i gave up on that thought
because the revenue sharing
apparatus is gone however there is some
thought about
going uh they've also suspended remember
we passed
laws saying they were to get 40 of meals
and rooms
and that's also been suspended in
several
budgets so maybe we would be able to put
more money into the
meals and rooms taxes that would go back
to towns
and hopefully would directly reflect
property taxes so
and that that'd be popular i think with
everybody
so those are the things that were
discussed that
might help pass a budget rather than
just keep building
uh more health and human services
services that
we're not certain are called for one of
the things that we did hear
the most talk about in the in our talks
and some of it in the
public hearing transitional housing
you want transitional housing for people
coming out of drug treatment
transitional
housing for people coming out of the
behavioral health hospitals transitional
housing of people coming out of prison
so you know and none of this has been
addressed very seriously
and of course it would have to be
somewhere
um where nobody would say not in my
backyard
one of the things i brought up was you
know some of these shuttered
shopping centers if they're on a a busy
way fair
where the people could walk to a job and
you turn
some of the portions of it into housing
then maybe that would work perfectly or
maybe
they'd be nearby enough other places to
get jobs so those some of the things i
was thinking of
and right away the governor said oh no
not not shopping centers but
they i think we've all seen some some uh
shuttered shopping centers around
they can be repurposed but anyway
something just just some things we all
thought about kicked around
but anyway i hope we all do the same
great
thank you and so will we see these will
we see some of these proposals
on monday or tuesday i don't think
they're fleshed out that fire yet and
and going to have a meeting again i
think on tuesday
uh because the the uh
ways and means are going to come back
with some more numbers
and so representative
it's my understanding that that we
really need as division three
to to be moving towards a vote and
that we i i was hoping i know it was an
aspirational hope but i was hoping that
we could actually
vote on an hb1 amendment on monday
if mr ripple can pull a rabbit out of
his hat and get it produced
and and and he can't even start until
this weekend so he is his sunday
uh is has been
claimed this is time sunday
so are we i just want to verify
the division three's plan to have
discussions on our version of the hb1
that we're on track for doing it monday
is my goal representative nordgren has
her hand
yes sir i was i was just looking for an
acknowledgement of my question
we're so we're on track for for money i
would support yes
okay so representative norden your hand
is up
yeah a couple of things i would just
remind
people that the last budget put a lot of
money into education funding
which was a huge tax cut for many
communities
and that's not included in the
governor's budget
um i would also comment that
i don't consider this last year a normal
year for spending or anything else with
coleman
i think obviously health human services
did lapse money but i think some of it
could have had to do with the fact that
their staff was otherwise occupied with
the crisis
and then i i wanted a little more
clarification on
what uh the democrats on the committee
could expect
on monday are you just going to bring in
a budget for us to
look at already prepared or
what do you plan to represent us on
monday
so i think that's a great question and
it's an opportunity to ask me
or for me to ask you what the standard
is
how how did how was the democrat
proposal presented to the republicans
two years ago
because if that's the standard please
tell me so that i can meet that standard
well we already did meet that standard i
mean
so we went line by line and so
we ended up there it wasn't a democratic
budget we did it all together
and and we presented it to the full
finance committee
so this wasn't just a democrat budget
and we gave it to the republicans we
worked every day
line by line every page of the budget
in the end we agreed or we didn't agree
but then that division three was brought
to the
full committee of finance
so we've already not taken all those
steps so i guess that's what i'm
trying to clarify and what to expect on
monday
i i think what we're going to present to
you on monday is
uh a draft amendment or maybe an actual
amendment to hb1
i would i would hope that you would have
an overnight to look at it
i i i that's probably a reasonable
request and depending on how
how things go um
you know we i i'm trying to schedule
things really intensely today
and on monday and we've left tuesday and
wednesday blank
so we do have a little bit of flex in
here
but but i'm i'm i'm trying to keep it on
us on an aspirational schedule and and
then we've got some
representative yes this is really a this
is sort of a question for kevin and
um maybe he won't maybe he doesn't maybe
he won't want to answer it or
doesn't know how it would work but
if this is going to be an amendment
that changes house bill
one i mean i assume it will
add some add some funds and some lines
and take away some funds and other lines
and
it's up and down will we be seeing an
amendment that
is the entire house bill
one i mean the whole the whole document
with all the ups and downs i wouldn't
ask him to do that i
i think we're focused on the division
three mission of dhhs and the veterans
home
i i don't i don't know that
on on on monday we need to be bringing
in division one and division two
i i i that that sounds odd to me
no did i say something i say something
about division one and two i'm sorry
would i i may have misunderstood you my
apologies
what i'm really trying to understand is
what kind of a document
will we receive will it be
the division three which is
health and human services will it be
that budget
with lines that go up or down i mean
because
if you take money away from some general
funds you're going to lose some federal
funds
i mean i i don't know what you have in
mind and so will we see the whole
health and human service budget with a
with adjustments
on different lines or will we just see
some sort of a piece of paper that
outlines where additions and
subtractions are happening
does mr mr ripple do you understand what
i'm trying to say
i i do understand and i think it ends i
think it depends on what the final
proposal ends up being so i'm not sure
what it'll look like at this point
okay so we could and we could end up
with a very large document
is that right i mean if it's the whole
budget
that that potential exists um but i
think it really depends on what's
hashed out over the weekend i'm still
not sure at this point
what that will be or what the resulting
amendments will look like
i think we've eliminated 100 pages
through uh
all federally funded or all other funded
so that's almost half the pages in in
that section
there's a couple hundred pages there so
this you know those are the ones we're
gonna have to revisit again
and there's others ones we already
looked at and added back almost to the
full amount
and so that took out another i don't
know 12
pages or so there isn't very many left
to look at
i don't i don't expect to see much
changes unless we can find out vacancies
and they're kind of reluctant to give us
those
so representative weiler i i do have a
document
dated 11 march or or the data is
effective
on 11th of march i'll i'll i'll share it
with you where they've
listed vacancies and and kevin i
i don't know the right name for the
level
that they've given it to me at there's
there's those are
there's about 14 or 15 items
what what level is that is that called a
department or what is that
i'm not sure if those were at the
division level they might have been a
little bit
um some some were at the division level
and some look like they were at the
bureau level
so i i do have some data it's not line
by line by any all right
but that that'll be a big help
representative
well i guess i would just say i'm pretty
despondent
because never before has one
party ever spent the weekend coming up
with a budget to present to the other
party
representative weiler knows that that's
not how we've ever done things
i've been presented before in
one division the chairman did all the
work
and presented it to us so here we go
so things are done differently all the
time
i guess uh it's happy hour somewhere
so so so maybe we should go find it
uh i i think uh i think we've talked
through this
and um we're uh we're getting ready to
adjourn is there any
last thing before we we adjourn for the
weekend
and officially we'll see each other
again 9 30 on monday morning
roger